Man, boom, and we're live.
What's happening baby? What's up Joe? How aii brother. I'm feeling great man.
Thanks for having me. You're looking great. Thanks.
When you're looking around the large, I threatened Joe before the show. I said,
you need to start off and tell me how beautiful. I am. Strong and pretty.
Wait, there's that your tee shirt company. Yeah, that's my clothing company.
It's also bunker branding and basically that's,
that's basically what this like a fist from your face.
I'm just afraid that everyone's going to hear me breathe like a fat Gal,
you know? How much did you do any cardio? I do most suddenly. Yeah.
If you watch strong men on, on the experiment, so like when you pull a truck,
let's 70,000 pounds and you pull it for a hundred feet with a harness,
restraining your chest, like not expulsion, but your chest expansion.
That's the hardest cardio I've ever done. I played football for a long time,
so I mean I can only imagine.
I was thinking that like you have to have some cardiovascular strength to do
some of those routines. Some of the,
some of the different challenges that you guys have to do for sure.
And normally like worlds, we'll start with like what we call load mentally.
So you'll have normally like four implements,
like you'll have two kegs and two sandbags and the kegs,
we'll both weigh 265 pounds and the sandbags will be three 30.
That's what we did last year, which was fucking brutal. But, um,
you'll have to load each one of them onto a platform that's about 60 feet away.
So, you know, if you get going, you can, it's not just cardio.
You have to have dye from strength to like, if you've got a weak diaphragm,
you're just going to fold.
I've seen guys blackout on and I've seen guys blackout at world's strongest man.
So what does that, how does it, how does one strengthens their diaphragm? Um,
what we do, the normal exercise we did, um,
it doesn't really have a name. It's just kind of something we made up.
You'll lay on your back and you take like a sand bag and put it over over your
or your upper abdomen and you'll expand. And you'll push out really hard.
And um, would you try and hold it for like say,
say like two minutes and you learn to take tight little breaths while flexing
your up upper abdominal abdominals. Whoa, I can spoke.
So you've got the weight on you right? And you just,
and you stay flexed and it's like, you know how you see fighters taking punches?
Like just to keep tight. Same similar thing. And so like me, I, I,
I have a big barrel gut, like a big chest and gut, but like it's solid.
I literally get like, I'll brag a little bit.
I've got side abs in the morning sometimes.
Actually I gotta say this I the best compliment I was ever given.
I put up a post and it was me drinking coffee in the morning just naked.
But like from like the hip up and somebody gave me a compliment.
That's actually comes from something you said. They said, damn,
Robert's got a really good dick root.
I think I vented Dick Route. Dick route is when those dudes, oh,
I don't understand why dudes do that.
They wear their shorts so low that you basically see the top of their cock
and you see the root. We've got nothing else to show.
So that's a weird weird move.
If you made a little Dickert that's all it comes up is just hey invented it.
I appreciate it. There was a very nice compliment.
Congrats on the Dick Root Bro.
It's just a weird thing that, I mean when did guys start doing it?
I get girls doing it, I get it. Right.
I just don't get guys pulling their shorts all the way down low.
Like that seems like you're just asking to get pants.
Like I don't understand like sagging I guess it like it comes out of prison
culture from what I heard.
I hate it now but I feel like I'm old man cause I used to do it as a kid used to
sag. Well I grew up in an area,
it was like it was a very low income area.
I don't know how to say that politically correct way to say it.
So like everybody was sagging. Yeah, like boxer shorts underneath.
You learned.
See when you start off with tidy whities and then everyone makes fun of you and
you're like, oh, right where I sit. You switched to boxes.
What a weird like style. Yeah.
I ran out of that by the time I was like 12 though. I was like,
this is ridiculous. Well,
my problem is like if somebody like grabs your pants, like you're done,
like you,
you're going to have to reach for your pants and then they're going to punch you
in the face. Like this is a tech. You're like asking your,
you're were like at a handicap. You sound exactly like my father right now.
Exactly what he would say. You're going to get your ass kicked.
I have friends that tried it like even 10 15 years ago, like guys my age.
I was like, Whoa, fuck, are you doing, it's still, they don't,
the thing now is skinny jeans and sagging, which is like, I don't know.
Counterproductive in a way I look. It just doesn't seem like it goes together.
Right. They're trying to combine styles and understand what they're doing. Yeah.
Well, I mean, if they've got a good enough dick route,
then maybe that's what it is. Like they just got to show the quad.
Like do you wear regular jeans or do you wear like stretchy type jeans?
Jeans. These are stretch. I love those man.
You can can't go back to regular jeans once you wear like rev towns or you know
barbells or any of those kinds of fuck all those regular jeans. You can't man.
No, I mean I ripped so many jeans just kind of sitting down. You know?
I think with your size,
like it must be fucking so hard to just find clothes and northern I'm built
differently. Like my waste is a,
is like a 40 but my instinct is like a 34 and so normally like if you find a 40
waist,
it's like a 28 or a 30 like so it's like for a shorter like try the guys.
Yeah. So still say fat guys and no one gets mad. Have you say fat girls?
People like, Hey yeah, oh, am I selling sensitive?
But fat guys don't catch a break.
Fuck about fat guy with the fat guys fucking deal with it. That guys are happy.
They're fat sometimes to them. That's a difference. Like fat girls,
we'll pretend they're happy, they're fat, but they're really sad on the inside,
so there you go. But fat guys, if they, especially if they drank, they're like,
Huh? Like per pressure.
Burke Chrysler does not seem to give a fuck that he's fat. No,
he does not have a problem with it. No. Takes his shirt off.
The moment he gets on stage doesn't care. He'll do it on, on daytime TV. Yes.
Doesn't people get mad at him? Well,
if he doesn't take his shirt off people like, hey, come on.
You're the sac guy that gets naked. Get naked. Dance Monkey. Yeah,
take it off. That's part of your Gig. It's like, what's his name?
A Gallagher without a watermelon, right? No sledgehammer.
Get the fuck out there. Let's, speaking of him,
what are you guys thinking for sober October? We really haven't decided yet.
The Burt wanted us to do some dance contest and you can suck my dick because he
wanted to do that so he could just win without working hard to just take his
clothes off and crazy. Woo Right. No chance.
But this about this,
what if they found a way to like score a dance thing a in a like so there is no
judgment and it was like points based on athletic types of movements or
something like that.
I'm sure like the Internet could come up with a way that it's like,
cause I understand what you're saying and what you're saying makes total sense
about how like you earned that shit. You want it to be regulated.
Not Someone's opinion.
Last year cause last year we literally were killing ourselves.
We were working out seven hours a day and I was just trying to grind those guys
in the ground. I was like I'm just going to take you to deep water and see.
It was awesome man. I loved it. I fucking loved it. I couldn't stop watching.
All part was talking shit and that's when I was like, oh,
I cannot have this guy when this is not going to happen.
That's where you fuck up.
I knew Ra was going to be a problem because he's crazy.
I tried really hard but he just didn't have a lot of experience grinding like
that his best.
He hung in there like you're a vet with that shit. Yeah.
Burt's trying to win this with fucking style points. He can fuck off. No, no.
I think if if, if,
if somebody can come up with a way that dancing is like regulated in a point
system that does nothing to do with people's opinion to where like it's,
I don't know even how you would do that way.
It's like there's an athletic type of movement that's required for this,
so learning that takes this and gives you, that gives you points.
That's the only way it would even work where it wasn't based on someone's
opinion. It's too much time too. That's the part of the problem.
It's like learning how to dance.
Like I did a movie once a zookeeper and I had to learn how to do this elaborate
dance with Leslie Bibb. That shit took forever,
weeks and weeks.
And you're like constantly training and drilling and going over the movements
and I don't even like that kind of thing. It's not like,
like if I'm doing martial arts and I'm training, I'm interested. That's,
I love that. I want to, I want to get better at it.
I didn't want to get better at dancing. I just want it to be over.
I just wanted to film the scene so I could fucking relax. Yeah, move on. Yeah.
So I don't know what we're going to do. We haven't decided. We're all waiting.
Yeah, I just said we should have a hold your breath competition. Oh,
that'd be cool. Yeah. Underwater. That takes practice. I mean,
I think you guys have to be off to add something in. My favorite part of
it was seeing you be like, no, fuck this.
Like we'll all go to the gates of hell. That's me. Like if someone, if someone,
I love talking trash, right. That's my thing. And in strongman,
it's not very popular. Like when I got in. Oh No, they don't.
It's very old school. Like you're supposed to do your work,
not act like you're supposed to get paid,
not act like you're supposed to want any attention,
not draw any attention towards yourself. Really. It's like,
it's like karate in like 1961, like it's school,
you know, be respectful of the way. And I totally get that. I understand that.
And I mean,
I don't think anyone can get to the top echelon without having that respect,
but it's,
it's ridiculous for people who've never been at that on that, uh,
on that level to tell other people how they're supposed to behave.
If I want to talk shit, I'm going to talk shit. I too,
like I was told I was talking shit to you when we first started coming out.
That's just what we do. It's fun. It's talking shit is fun. And also it's like,
I feel like that makes it more entertaining and we want more eyes on the sport.
Exactly. I mean, that's what my, my argument about d UFC,
I always like it when people talk some shit. Right. And, and win or lose.
Sometimes you have to eat that. Like, what's that? The kid that been aspirin.
Exactly. A flat line. That was brutal. But I mean,
he also took that on the chin. He put up a post like right after that like,
well that sucked. Yeah. He takes on sham better than anybody.
He's got a great personality and massive all said, it's not even over. Listen,
he goes, I don't like that dude. He goes, if I see him at whole foods,
he's getting smacked up. Oh Shit.
I can't imagine the guy flatlines you with the fucking fastest ever.
Kao and UFC history and he's promising you that if you're looking for Brussels
sprouts smack in the face. Yeah. Oh Man.
He already gave him two extra shots of the face, which by the way,
people are giving him shit for. It's, that's his job. Yes.
It's go to the referee stops you. Well,
especially when there's a heated contest like that where you talk so much shit
and and salted Mazda dolls,
manhood he talked about isn't ethnicity taught these weeds.
He said a lot of shit that really pissed Mossville off. Right? And he's like,
why didn't he had a statement? I was like,
why is it okay to talk all this shit online about me before the fight?
But then after I knocked him out, I'm not supposed to showboat.
I'm not supposed to celebrate. Get the fuck Outta here.
If you've got a problem with it, stop him winters. Get to do what they want.
He's ice cold man. When he said it's not over,
if I see this kid smacked off like, oh my God, that is so intense.
Savage that I loved though was so brilliant because aspirin always grabs your
legs and if you get that close to him, he's going to think like,
almost like he has to grab you. Right. It's his instinct. And you saw him,
like I saw somebody put a video up in practice and he would,
he rounded up like out to the outside and then acted as if it was going to be
just a normal step. And then it's two quick steps on the knee. Oh,
and you see how stiffy was before he hit the, I'm sure you saw, but damn,
he was, his head was up and then one leg was up. I mean,
he was stiff though. That was a row
here. Here he was practicing. Yeah.
It was in an absolutely roomless Keio and it's the fastest ever UFC Kale at five
seconds.
But really he was out cold at 2:00 AM he just took the rough a few seconds to
get there. Yeah, whatever. Maybe three, I guess. Maybe. I mean,
whatever it took for him to run over there, it seems like two seconds.
Who was like one, 1000 totes over? Oh yeah.
Oh fuck. Well I used to got a lot of facetime before he got in the ring. Yeah.
And you ever thought about fighting as big as you are? No. Um,
I mean I messed around with like wrestling and stuff.
I know I work with John Jones with the supplement company for awhile. Oh really?
Yeah. Then I know a lot of fighters. I know a lot of old school wrestlers.
I've got a lot of like friends in the industry, but I'm,
I'm fucking old school wrestler wrestlers are pro wrestling pro wrestlers site.
Yeah, the totally different thing. It's just,
but still that would be a great avenue for you to write.
I did think about that for a while too. It's just a contractually it's just,
it's a shit show I'm sure like injuries and all that stuff too would take you
out of competition, but plus they want the, why am I now?
I started and worked my ass off just to get like a little piece of that pie and
when you go to the WWE or something, something like that,
you have to step back all the way, all the way to the ground level.
You have to earn your stripes and I understand that. But like I have,
I have a son, I have a family. I take care of people,
I can give up everything that I've earned,
like basically breaking myself for five years just to crawl back up and
hopefully, you know, end up where I am. But, you know, it's a cool thing.
I also almost a big fan of wrestling when I was a kid, you know,
back in the day. And uh, you know, like I love watching it go on.
One of my buddies right now, a guy who was a strong man with me,
his name's Bron Stroman and he's in the WWE. He's a, he's a bad ass,
so I love watching him do it sometimes.
Do you follow Pooja ski fighting and MMA? I haven't,
I haven't seen a lot of his MMA stuff. I know, I know him and I've watched him.
He's, he's freaking crazy man. He's fucking people up too, man. He's,
he's really getting better. Like when he first started fighting,
he was just this giant dude who's just swinging arm punches and if he hit you,
he would fuck you up. But he got crazy and he decided to fight Tim Silvia,
who is a former UFC heavyweight champion. And Tim beat the shit out of him.
It was horrible. Like I don't know why he thought he could beat Tim. Sylvia.
He thought that Tim was washed up or older. How old is to know?
How long has he been out of the game? He's definitely in his forties. Yeah. Um,
I don't know. How old is Tim? Tim's dry and now you know,
like four pounds for today. See that's me. I'm foreign and pounds.
I can't cut both my legs off to make two 65.
I think that's so weird that they have a two 65 cutoff.
Cause heavyweight is supposed to be the biggest guy. Like in boxing.
You remember that Dude Value Webb who fought? He who did he fight?
He fight failed.
He was like seven feet tall is his giant ass Russian dude.
He was fucking enormous. His boxer, but he was well over 300 pounds,
seven foot tall. It'd be skinny at three. He was big man.
He had gigantic Titus or whatever it is.
When you move the pituitary gland tumor,
what does that see if you can find that guy value of who I think he fought
Holyfield I think Holyfield peed him for the title,
which is even crazier when you think of that.
Holyfield started his career at 109.
He started his career as a cruiserweight 95 pounds. I don't know. Yeah, yeah.
That's it. Here's the Guy Evander Holyfield and value of,
and this is in 2008 leave the size of that guy man.
And he get the fuck out of here. He's so big man.
But I think when a guys are that big,
like with that giant Titus or GI can't tie to say that they're always hurting.
Like everything hurts.
Your knees hurt your elbows and like you can't really move that good.
I know a lot of guys, Andre the giant was my hero growing up.
Like he was like my first real hero and um,
I knew a lot of guys who had known him.
I actually met a Roddy Roddy Piper like three weeks before he passed and I was
wanting to name him Andre the giant shirt. And we,
we got to sit in a VIP section at a, at a baseball game and he was ass man.
He was so cool.
I wanted to get that guy on the podcast and Tony Hinchcliffe was actually trying
to set it up, but then he died. Yeah. He used to go to the comic store a lot.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. He'd even went on stage a couple times there.
He would just tell stories, man. He was awesome. He was,
he was like one of the first guys also to crossover into movies.
Obviously Andre was first, he did a few guest spots. Yeah.
But uh, he was a star of day live. Remember that?
Which is like the John Carpenter movie. That's a great fucking movie. Huge.
Yeah. So he was in that too. Cool. He was a fun guy, man.
There were actually, um, what I was, what we're doing the whole,
basically the reason I was here to talk about TV show this next season,
season two we're going to do we, so I'll start over.
The whole TV show is based on us doing acts of strength throughout for strong
men throughout history. So what is the name of the show called?
The history strongest man and strongest man and ESPN show. It's on history. Oh,
it's on history channel. Oh, that's awesome. So, um,
one of the episodes is next season we're hoping to do is Andre the giant,
which we're gonna talk about.
But what we do is we travel to where a historical strongman lived or where he
did this famous feed of strength. And we,
we recreate those feats of strength and we kind of talk about who they are as
people and stuff and bring the light,
like a lot of the cool aspects that most people lose. So like it'd be cool to,
you know,
take somebody like Andre the giant and like meet with his daughter and figure
out like little parts that people haven't really paid attention to and bring
that to light. We did. Um,
one of my favorite episodes we did was this Guy Peter Francisco, who was a,
he was born in [inaudible] think it was a
Colombia. I'm, I'm, I'm on my mind. Mistaken paradigm and Cisco, there we go.
The Virginia giant in Portugal. There you go. So he was born to like, um,
a wealthy family and was kidnapped and sold as a slave and he ended up,
uh, in, in America and at 16, he signed up to fight for a,
in the revolutionary war. He was six foot seven, six foot eight.
Just this giant of a man, especially 17, seven. Wow.
Oh yeah. There was nobody that big back then. You know,
like a lot of people don't realize Jack Johnson,
former heavyweight champion who they called the Galveston giant.
I think he was only six, three or six. Two or six pole.
Jack Johnson's y'all big. It was towered over everybody else. He fought. Yeah.
Like Rocky Marciano was 185 pounds, 89 pounds. Like somewhere around there.
He says he was only six foot tall.
But what that's what Google puts popped up from. It's like Wikipedia. Hm. Uh,
I think he's a little taller than that, but he was a giant back then.
They called them the Galveston giant. Well, everybody was so poor.
Then they didn't have any food. You know the turn of the century.
Everybody's struggling. That's crazy. That's crazy.
This was six two Jack Dempsey. Six one wow. And Marsianno I think it was five,
ten five times believe it was fun.
I think Marciano's five 10 185 pounds.
It's crazy because Jack Johnson towered over everybody and was fucking everybody
up. I mean it's a food thing, man. No one had any fucking food back then.
If you look at the size of the people that fought during the civil war,
they were tiny ass people. Like really tiny, like 125 pound men.
I can't even go back further. All the scouts Fisher,
him like they make an out like he's giant.
Like look at the picture on the right, look, look at his back, look at his back.
He is, he is pretty direct. Pretty Gash war.
He's definitely jacked for, I mean look, he's,
he's big but I mean in comparison to a real heavyweight today,
like if you put him next to Anthony Joshua,
you know like Josh would be tolerant or Deontay wilder was six. He was he six,
seven, yeah. Or Frances and Gando, you know,
big giant dudes, real legit giant dudes. People that weren't that big back then.
So that guy, the wrestler, the Portuguese Guy,
I must've been unbelievable to see someone that big back.
Same. Yeah.
And what was cool is like there's a lot of cool things that you find out like
George Washington,
how to quote on his gravestone that was said that there were several battles
that we would not have had go the same way.
And we don't know if we would've even been able to win the war if it wasn't for
him. Why it was a one man army for George Washington to stay that,
that's huge. That's crazy. So it was cool to get to talk about him and,
and all the things he had done and bring, you know,
show a little love for a guy who I'd never even heard of. You know,
like there was the story. He was on the battlefield and uh,
he was pulling people off of horses and like basically beating them to death
cause we ran out of bullets.
And then as he goes marching up towards this guy who pulls his musket to shoot
at him and the Musket misfires.
He takes the Musket from him and beats him to death with his own musket.
Oh my God. Stuff like that. Or when the, when the battle was over,
they had a canon stuck in the mud and this is one of the feats of strength we
did.
They had a canon stuck in the mud and he didn't want the British to end up with
it. So he just yanked the thing off of the wheels,
puts it on a shoulder and marches off with it. How much does it weigh?
It depends. Depends on the story that you believe. When we went,
I don't want to get too much into it, but when we went,
that's the biggest question was because anybody who's ever lifted a bunch of
weight and thrown things around, it's like, that sounds pretty crazy.
Cause cannons can go from anywhere of like, like a normal field.
Canon will be like 300 pounds,
but they've got field cannons from that era that are thousand pounds. And,
and depending on who tells the story, that's what you found,
which we try and figure out where the fuck would you even get that on your
shoulder if it's in the mud,
the mud. So you don't have a firm ground to push off against. Right.
So we're in the port court squashing around the mud and you've got this giant
canny you're trying to throw in your shoulders, no handles, fucking amen.
Right after
battle to the guy was the guy was a savage. It was, it was really cool.
And then afterwards the,
he ended up a wealthy man and was taken care of and you know, and it was,
it was a really cool story. So it was,
I was like actually pretty proud to get to tell that one. That's awesome.
A lot of them were like that.
How did you get involved with doing strongman competitions? Um,
I played football, I played football for a long time and then, you know,
football was done with me and I basically, I was just,
I didn't want to have a real job,
just to be totally honest. I'm not a,
not a nine to five sitting in an office guy. Anybody is.
I don't think so either. I really don't. That's terrible way to live.
And so in this people listening right now, they're like,
that's what I'm fuck this place, get out. And I,
you can some telling you,
I convinced one of my best friends to quit his job and come with me to China for
a week and then of course you have to struggle and find your way.
But then after that it was, it was the best thing you've ever,
we're done. Yeah, definitely better off being a nomad. Yeah. Is Fine.
Something you, you'll be, you'll feel, feel better. You know. Exactly.
Like I was talking to a friend of mine today about Thailand at about, uh,
like when I went to Thailand last year,
kind of like reshaped my idea of like what makes people happy because everybody
over there is wearing flip flops and fucking shorts. Everything is real cheap.
Food's real cheap, there's no extravagance and everybody's happy.
And like my friend John Wayne par, he says it's the land of smiles.
That's what he calls it. And I was like, okay.
He lived there and train there for a long time. But I'm like, well, I, I,
I didn't get it until I went there. And I'm like, God damn.
And everybody's happy, but you'll drive by, you'll see like a fucking kid,
a baby sitting on the gas tank of a motorcycle while guys driving and the,
the ladies behind him and she's,
she's holding onto the guy's waist and he's like,
got one hand on the handlebars and one hand on a baby. And I'm like,
what in the fuck am I seeing? They're
wearing flip flops and they're just, everyone's happy. No. [inaudible].
You remember Thailand, but it's like that in parts of China, like rural,
rural parts of China. It's a lot like that.
I've seen like people tied to each other on a, on a motorcycle.
Oh Geez. What a terrible idea. So bad.
[inaudible] sent me a fucking horrible video yesterday of this guy.
These two guys are riding like assholes on a bridge,
like with motorcycles weaving in that traffic and one guy loses control of the
bike and he hits the cement barrier on the edge of the bridge and then goes off
the edge. Oh my God. Yeah. Just watch it. Bang, boom. When he flies off,
it's like all I've been seeing the last week two, we just did this. Here it is.
Jamie. Got It. Ready. Jamie's the fastest Googler in the west. You're on it.
See, these guys are fighting. Look at this. Oh, he touched too. Yeah.
You see him put his foot down and try and collect himself. Watch. Yeah.
And watch. When you see,
when they pull over and you get to look at how far this motherfucker dropped,
like he's done zero. That is, that is,
that's that guy's got his hand in his pockets. Of course it's Florida.
It looks like it. Sure. It's Florida fucking asshole. So it's gotta be Florida.
It probably landed right on an alligator.
He would've been fine with. Now shoot up. I read a story in Florida.
Tampa, Florida course called it. Of course, man,
it's is a fucking mess, man. I was there for two weeks.
I was scared shitless the whole time I've been everywhere. It's Florida.
I was like paying attention to everyone walking around, see like bat salts,
eating people's faces. Everything fucked up happens there. They, uh,
they just issued a shoot to kill on Iguanas.
They're trying to get people to kill his money.
Guan apparently there's so many guavas there that they're digging holes under
bridges and roads and roads are collapsing. Yeah.
Buildings are collapsing because they're digging.
They're digging trenches under the foundations. That's so crazy.
And they're big like five feet long. When he got, what's his smile on his face?
Florida Guana Hunter mistakes pool boy four Ilana shoots him
Florida. You gotta get your shit together guys. Come on. Not going to happen.
My sister lives in Florida. She's probably listening to this. Laura,
get out of there. Run, run for your lives. Fucking goofy place to live, man.
It really is. It's so crazy. It's a goofy place to live. But for people like,
like chaos and party and it's fun. That's, that's, that's what it's all about.
Yeah. My friend Billy Corban, he uh,
made a cocaine cowboys one and two and he fucking loves it down there and he's a
smart guy and he lives in Miami and he just fucking loves it. He, he,
he enjoys the chaos. Yeah. I mean,
I guess if you can separate yourself enough that you don't feel crazy on the
inside, cause I don't know how you can, I couldn't do that here now lay like,
I mean la is not even a quarter of that,
but like I lived in Playa del Ray and in Sherman oaks for two and a half,
two and a half years. And I was like, I gotta the fuck. I know what the problem
with this place is,
there's so much instability because there's so many people that want to be
something other than what they are. Right. That's a big part of this place.
Yeah. Whereas I, you live in Texas now, days are just, those are people.
Those are real people. I fucking love Texas. They are, they are people.
They don't have any illusions to becoming famous from some fucking reality show.
Or if they do, they're the anomaly. They're not the norm out here.
It seems like everybody, well not everybody,
but a Julian percentage of the people that came here came here with some dream.
They came up with some dream of being an actor or some dream of being famous.
Some dream of, you know,
of making it and then they got jobs and so there's this like weird instability
and this, this need for acceptance and this need for recognition.
And you know, you'd go to Montana, you don't get any of that.
You get regular people. You go to Colorado or Colorado is now filled,
was toners Colorado's guys. Now it's getting a little, a little different.
Well now, now that the shrooms are all illegal, their, yeah.
I'm wondering what's going to trying to bring in wolves.
My friend Johnny Hamilton told me they're trying to bring it,
they're trying to stop mountain lion hunting and trying to bring in wolves.
Really? What? Yeah,
well they brought in wolves in the 90s to Yellowstone, I remember.
And that went really badly. Right? Well, it depends on who you ask.
The wildlife people think it went really well because it did a lot of great
things in terms of like, it preserved, um,
a lot of plant species that were getting decimated by elk and deer.
The problem is like,
it happens so quickly that the elk and deer really didn't understand what was
going on until they were decimated. And they, you know,
some places they've lost more than 50% of their populations,
but then other people say that they really should have never been that high in
the first place.
It's hard to understand who's cause like you try to be objective. But you know,
I hunt and I eat a lot of elk and deer. So for me,
I hear it from hunters that it's a terrible thing,
but then you hear it from people that are concerned with balance and wildlife
ecology in a balanced ecosystem. They think it's a good thing.
And so it's a very, it's very controversial.
They don't think there ever should have been these giant herds of elk, you know,
like a thousand elk in a field. They think that's on. That's unnatural. Huh.
And that's akin to what, um,
apparently what they experienced when a lot of the native Americans were wiped
out by plague when the European soldiers arrived,
when they talk about these great herds of Buffalo, like millions of Buffalo,
they think that the reason why there were so many buffalo was because like
literally 90% of the native Americans were killed by European disease.
And so these buffalo for the, for the, during that time period that happened,
they just bred, like my friend Dan Flores wrote a book on it. Really,
really interesting shit because most people just assume that that's just how it
was back then. The buffalo were everywhere and then the white man came,
shot all the buffalo.
But apparently the buffalo were only s all over the place because the white man
came and gave diseases to the native Americans.
Right. That's fucking nuts, man. So the balance issue.
So I don't know if it's a good idea to bring wolves around people that are on
mushrooms either. That too. If it was me, I'd try and pet it, you know?
But we're good buddy. I'm reaching out to the forest.
I have a friend of mine, she lives in, uh, a place, uh,
in the mountains above boulder. And, uh, there's MT lines in my neighborhood.
Like, uh, when I was living up there at mount mind ate my fucking dog. And uh,
she, uh, she was like, well,
I just set my intention when I go into the forest and I let the forest know I am
praying, said I'm here for you. She was a yoga instructor. She might be,
she might be a little crazy and rest in peace. She's still alive,
apparently still alive now.
My stay mountain's lying. Yeah. But it worked out great for secrete and Roy.
Right. There's already caught.
The Colorado already has some wolves that had been in Colorado. They're there.
They're entering in the fringes and from other areas where there they're
present. Like my oming, you know, in Idaho there's,
there's wolves that are neighboring Colorado that will eventually make their way
into Colorado if they give it enough time. The reintroduction of wolves.
The issue with that is like,
it's abrupt and the animals might not know what's going on and they also make a
lot of money off of their hunting. Um, the, like the,
the tags and all the, the economy that comes from people that hunt there.
Colorado's a big hunting state. So it was a last, I heard it was those,
there was the big articles they were bringing in into Montana. Right?
The giant ones they're bringing in from Canada into Montana. Yeah,
but they're just wolves. Like, it's weird. It's weird. It's a gray wolf for,
it's a gray wolf, you know, it's just a wolf. It's like,
but they are bigger when they live in colder climates because it's a mammal
thing. Like mammals, like deers. If you'd like a deer in Texas,
south Texas, a deer, a big deer is like a hundred plus pounds, 150 pounds.
Whereas if you go to Saskatchewan, it's cold as fuck.
Those deer like 300 pounds when they're fully grown. Right. Like a big male.
It's like a 300 pound deer, which is crazy. Yeah. The more than double the size,
but it's because of the cold. Right. I had never thought about it.
That makes sense. I love Texas. What part you live in? I'm in new Braunfels,
which is right outside of San Antonio. Oh, nice. I've never been in San Antonio.
It's Nice, man. San Antonio was a cool, shitty.
We're actually right between Austin and San Antonio. Oh, that's great.
It's perfect. This is like that river walk area. Supposed to be dope.
That's cool. I mean, that's like the tourist thing, you know? It's like, um,
it's what they do. It's like go in and see the Hollywood sign. There's, if you,
if you want to have a good time,
just let me know when you're coming to Texas and we'll go and do some redneck
shit. Well, my Brent,
my friend John Dudley was just there with the black rifle coffee guys. And uh,
they went to some ranch that's just outside of San Antonio that the fucking
astronauts used to go to.
He said this least photos of Neil Armstrong with a fucking deer.
Hell yeah. Texas. That is a uniquely place. Like when other,
I think when other people think of America, they really think of Texas.
Most people, I mean, if they're thinking America,
they'll say that it'll be Texas. But if it's, if it's like Hollywood,
they'll say California. You know,
those are the two some people like every once in a while I think New York,
but I think what people think about like crazy gun toting,
screaming at football, you know,
like that's Texas guaranteed 100% drive out of box.
I'm sure it's a fun place. You know, a lot of fun,
lot less regulations, a lot more um, self, uh, self accountability, you know.
Well, they have fucking zebras and giraffes and shit everywhere. They're loose.
Yeah. Running around. I work with, um, with, uh,
a car but just became a credited zoo that works a lot with confiscated animals.
Like they've got hundreds of animals that basically some redneck was like, oh,
I'm going to have a white line, can't take care of it. So they take it,
they just folks who they've got high in this abandoned house and uh,
they were in the house in Texas and a,
they're walking around his house smoking weed and they walked into a room with a
fucking tiger in a cage. Oh my God.
They called the police and they had to police come in and rescue this fucking
tiger. But this was in an abandoned house. Oh Shit. The house. Oh my God.
There's a, just a T. I mean they weren't sure. Like here you find it here. Oh,
you got these God damn pop up ads
to getting craftier and craftier with these popups.
And then you don't know if like clicking exits gonna download something. Texas.
Man, look at this. Texas manager's abandoned home to smoke weed,
finds tiger and stylish and stats fucked up, man. Yeah,
he thought he was hallucinating.
He said it was in a Reiki dink cage in the home's garage.
But it's weird when you treat animals like property,
you know when you can just do whatever you want with them. And that's how Texas,
that's how Texas views exotics. Anything that's not like if you're,
if you have white tail deer in Texas, they have pretty liberal tags.
Like you can shoot a good number of them, but you have to get tags. Right.
But if you have like a, a black buck,
which is an African animal or a Neil guy or something like that,
you shoot as many as you want, right? Yeah. They just do whatever you want.
You sell them to your friends. What does it say?
It was secured only with a screwdriver and a nylons trap. Christ,
I hope this guy got some kind of fucking punishment.
The guy who own the fucking house, that's a dick move. Man.
That's a beautiful tiger. Yeah.
This something really fucked up about seeing tigers locked up.
I don't even like the fact that they feed them. I mean,
I feel like you should just let something loose in there.
That's what I was saying. That's what I was saying. But from what I already,
Roland, exactly what I was told was that that was just not a PC.
Like it wasn't acceptable, I'm sure. Do you ever,
do you ever see the footage of when the US soldiers overtook Baghdad? They had,
uh, they had zoos and Baghdad. And what they would do is the,
the lions knew it was happening. So they would, uh,
let these goats out and these goats would be wandering around and then they
would open the door and aligns would sprint.
Cause they knew exactly what because it was feeding time. Goats had no idea.
They let the goats out and the goats to be like, oh,
just hanging out being a goat.
And then they would open up this fucking door and US soldiers filmed it. Oh.
And these lions just make this fucking mad sprint to these goats and just maul
them. And that's how they ate. They both got pissed. People shouldn't be pissed.
That's what it is. If you watch a fucking up, you want it,
you go and see a parrot eaten seeds. That's what it eats. Right. You know,
may maybe really identify with seeds and you feel like that's brutal.
Myrtle murder of seeds. Yeah. That lion wants to do that.
That's what makes them a lion. It makes them happy. It's what they have to do.
You know, it's like there's a lot more, um, people getting published,
not publicity, but there's a lot more people showing that side of things.
At least I was, we were talking about right before we came on,
there's this Instagram page called nature's metal. Yes. I look,
I've taken badass taken down for awhile. He had a, he got back up,
but he's, he has one of the very best pages on the take it down.
That's all he does. He didn't,
he had nothing to do with any of those situations.
It's not like he like had some kind of ulterior motive and came in and put these
animals in the situation. That's just reality today.
Instagram is cracking down hard lately. I don't understand it.
They take all kinds of stuff down for virtually no reason. Hmm. It's weird.
Odd. He's someone that's just to complain enough and they'll take it down.
They need to get that fixed where it's instead of like a computer.
I understand it's a lot, right? It's a, it's a lot of people.
So having a computer regulate that just doesn't work. No,
it's not just a computer regulate that. If someone can target you,
like say maybe you could be doing something and they just decide you're
offensive and then just start it like make a targeted campaign to complain about
your content. Yeah. So one of those tattoo girls, she got a, her,
her, her post removed just having her hand above her crotch,
like covering her crotch or legs spread and showing all their tattoos and they,
they took down her her page like she's, but she's covered up.
Makes no sense. I mean she doesn't have pants on but you can't see anything.
Alright, fuck. Are we doing this? Americans are in legs. Fuck kind of shit.
Is this Texas needs to open the new Instagram. What's that?
I say that's different than what nature's metal is though.
He might've gotten trouble for taking life photographers copywritten works and
reposting because she's wildlife.
She's being wildly and that's her natural habitat. She's young. Jamie,
I was talking about this with a friend of mine yesterday. Would communist? No,
like active enforcement. Let's copyright laws.
At what point if, if like, you know, youtube, some of the stuff is good,
even on Instagram stumps stuff they let go and some stuff they don't.
At what point are people supposed to understand what is okay and what is not
okay? Yeah, it's hard, but you also have to think of it.
How many people are on Instagram? Let's just guess. I don't know.
Let's guess how many people you think I'm not either, but fuck. Let's see.
We think 100 million more than,
there's probably close to a billion, maybe 500 million,
like somewhere in that range I would say. All right,
I'm going to go with 300 million. 300 million in one place.
Jim, you go with a billion. Yeah. How many people are on Instagram?
1 billion people use Instagram every month. Jesus Christ,
but that's 1 billion use. Yeah.
[inaudible] are on that don't even use it.
So it could be like two does that include the Russians
one bill yet? It's a lot. Jesus Christ. That's crazy.
Well Twitter still lets porn happen. He would still have porn on Twitter.
What do I say?
It's just because it has a 18 plus like warning or something like that doesn't
even my feed I I'll be scrolling through my feed like I've got to make sure my
kids will never grabbed my phone cause if they're looking through my phone I'm
like hey the age they might be in there though.
Because when you sign your account you say how old you are and you've built into
the system.
I'm like sense a lot of those things are protections for people that are under
13 and I don't know why there's that Internet rule,
but like there is some government protections they need to be watching out for
the miners that are online and that makes sense. But does that happen?
Is that the case with like youporn or places like that? You just go there?
I don't know but come on. I don't know where the,
like if the kid like a kid knows what it is, I don't know.
The line is the coupon. What is this point? How do you get there?
Here's a browser. Do you want to browsers? Well,
when the virtual porn, a fucking world opens up,
that's when things are going to get very squirrely. Dunkin said it's too real.
Dunkin had an HTC vibe and he was watching porn with the helmet on,
which I only want to be a fly on the wall. Watch him standing,
standing there beating off, looking at a 17 foot tall vagina in front of him.
Haptic suit would be the next step and those are here so I don't know what
that's like. If they could sinked it up those, I mean I've done that,
that place. We talked about the void. You ever do a virtual reality plays?
It's pretty dope.
They have a new one that I just saw in Vegas that some new one that was looked
like you going to a warehouse and you shooting at things but you a,
you put on this helmet and you enter into this room and there was two different
ones that I went on.
One was a star wars one and one was a wreck it Ralph one and it's crazy man.
You look around, I mean the entire thing is animated like your,
the above you below you, you see the ground, you see storm troopers,
they shoot at you, you feel the laser beams hit your chest because you're
wearing a vacit that like vibrates.
When you get hit and you walk into a room where there's fire and you feel the
heat, it's, it's getting really interesting.
When you're in that like a, say this room was empty,
would you walk around as if it was like an entirety? The entirety of the room?
Yeah. You can walk around.
They have it set up so that they have rooms that you go into where you open
doors or doors open for you and you see the door open like in virtual reality,
but a real door does open while that fake door that you're seeing opens and then
you go into it and then they have these plastic guns that you pick up, you know,
so you actually pick up the gun when you're holding it.
It looks like a stormtrooper weapon or you know, like a star wars weapon.
That's cool man. It's getting weird. It's going to, it's going to be weird. But,
but I think what's interesting is like that kind of stuff is so much less
satisfying that to bring it back to like what you do then,
like something that you have to really work for and it's really difficult and
it's a very visceral, real feeling,
like the feeling of accomplishment you get when you do something virtual.
We'll never be able to compare with the feeling that you do when you do a
physical, visceral thing to feel it in your fucking bones.
Yeah. You feel it. You live it. I, uh,
when I was doing world's strongest man in Botswana, Africa,
I told my bicep and um, I just was getting beat up over and over again.
I was just so wrecked. My body wasn't accepting cause I,
I had went from football to strong man and in football we'd never done dead
lifts. It was all hand cleans and power cleans, which by the way,
just quick little tip that dead lifts the fear.
If you're dead lifting to be a better dead lift are fine.
If you're not doing that for deadlifts sake, then don't fucking do it.
The risk to reward ratio is a joke for deadlift, for deadlifts.
And a lot of people aren't going to like that. I'm saying that.
But if you go into any NFL gym in any Division One College football gym,
in any athletics where people are actually getting paid and it matters what
they're doing, they're not dead lifting.
We their hand cleaning and power cleaning. Why is that? Because the,
the risk reward ratio, like there's,
it's so hard to be a great dead lifter and to not risk your low back and to be
using your upper back properly and you know, just there's so many little uh,
um, chances for you to get hurt, you know, hamstring stuff. That was,
that was me. Uh, my first world's strongest man.
I was the only rookie in the finals. Perot, China. How much weight is that?
That was 880 pounds.
Me and my pink chucks
I way less than that now. I'm less of a bowling ball though.
Really? Wow. That. Well they made those waits.
Ridiculous looking too,
right? Well nothing. That right there is a something we overhead press too,
so they'll take some of the weights out of it and it's so flimsy when you clean
it.
It's like basically like holding that earthquake bar that you have out there.
It's just like that and it's fucking brutal.
So they take weight out of that round thing. And what is in that round thing?
Well, there's several different attachments to it,
so maybe some of them way different. I've never like been a part of that.
But uh,
like either that or it unscrews at the end and they take weights out of it and
I'm not positive exactly what we leave the NFL or you leave PR playing football
and you were you in the NFL? No, I had a brief shot at it. Never.
It never actually got to do it. No, I was. So what, what kind of transition?
Like what is the transition to get into strong man went from that to uh,
I was security guard in Santa Cruz at this place called the catalyst,
which is why I worked for like six years.
It's a really cool bar slash concert venue. So I was like spoiled.
I got to hang out with Rob Zombie and Willie. That shit. Yeah, it was cool.
I will support Rob Zombie. I geeked out really hard for it. That's dope.
It was fun. Yeah. We're working on getting him here, dude. He'd be awesome.
I'm sure he would be. Yeah, he was really cool.
I'm sure he is really into horror movies, man, dude. And he does the best one.
I love his horror movies, man. They're wild. I'm a huge fan. Huge Fan.
He's like the Quentin Tarantino of whore. Awesome.
But it's such a weird transition, you know? Yeah.
Going from being a rock star to a horror film director,
he's just crazy in the head.
And his brother is actually the lead singer apartment 5,000 really? Yeah.
Oh Wow. There's a family. So it didn't,
I went to security and I was working there and a buddy of mine who I'd played
junior college ball with was just obsessed with strong men and I'd never heard
of it. I never watched it. Like when I was growing up, we were poor.
Like there was 10 of us in a three bedroom house and from high school on like we
didn't have electricity. So like we didn't watch TV. We, we would play outside.
We had a trampoline and electricity in high school on the weekends my dad worked
for Caterpillar Cashman equipment.
So on the weekends he'd bring home a little generator and he'd plug that in and
we'd have like three things we could use.
But that was like the hot water heater would work for the weekend.
And then like maybe the TV on Saturday night or something like s t g I f Ah,
I mean it wasn't, I mean, as a kid it's not that big of a deal, you know,
like you just go play with your brothers outside. So, but like,
I never knew what strong man was because of that. I mean, I had no idea.
So he was obsessed with it and he kept trying to get me to do it. And then, uh,
w went home and googled it, checked it out. Actually,
I don't know if it was Google, I might've youtube did back then. Who knows?
Who knows what we had. But, um, you know, I,
I was excited and went and tried it out. And first day,
the amateur world record at log press was like 320 pounds at the time.
And I had no idea,
but the first day I hit 330 pounds and just put it down.
And I looked over at my buddy and I was like, you know, how'd that look?
And he's like, get the fuck Outta here.
Like he's been trying his whole life to do this. Just came in and took it.
And then, uh, eight months later, I mean,
six months later I was competing in England and, uh, had my pro card,
two months after that, I was in China at that photo right there.
[inaudible] man, that was the only rookie in the finals.
So is it the log thing is it, did the awkwardness of like holding onto a log,
getting it into your
hands and yeah. And it's, it's actually,
it's a lot healthier for your shoulders instead of being, uh,
how would you call that with your hands right there instead of protonated or
something? Yeah, we get which one is which.
I like it when trainers used that though. You know what you talking?
This guy's got his shit together. There's fat duty in French fries.
So, um, yeah, I mean, um, so it's better for you.
It's much better for your wrists and your shoulders. And also like,
that's what my hair co's, Jamie Shauna's grip [inaudible] grip.
So yeah, neutral grip is much better for your wrists and shoulders.
Okay. Like so handles like this. They say that with bench press as well.
Like those benches, they have new bars that have handlers from rogue. Yeah.
Awesome. Awesome road. Makes good equipment. Yeah.
I use all their shit at my house in here. I know it didn't pay me.
It's not free. I buy all of it. Zam here either. But they're the best.
It's the best shit. So, um, we went to worlds and then, oh yeah,
I totally lost the whole game. First of all,
you beat the fucking world record log pressed the first time.
The world record amateur amateur world here with the,
that's hilarious. So it was good. My, that's the pro record right now.
The American records had been mined for four years and that was 211 kilos.
And what does that pound fucking four 68 for like that.
Is this you here as me? Yeah. This is in Australia. In front of Arnold.
Jesus Christ sent home. Was there. That's his competition.
This is my competition. This is so this is a log press right here. Yup.
That's a skinny log too. This was a hard log to use, but a,
this was a buddy of mine had that record and he passed away and I wanted it to
be the one to take it from him after he had died and that that was this moment.
Jesus Christ. I looks at it and you show me. Show off a little bit too.
I like to do this after I get it up. Wow.
So that's the world record, not on American record. Who's the world record?
The world record. I like to hold it up there and talk shit all.
Every time you see a record broken,
the guy gets it to here and then he just throws it down. Don't count.
It doesn't count. So the,
the world record is a 219 kilos, I believe.
Something like that. Something, something right around there.
It might've been two to 20 how closely are you to that? I can,
I can break it right now. Oh, in January, Robert, I'm going to London.
I'm going to give London a little introduction to Texas a, uh,
what do you call it? Texas pride and Texas power lifting for sure. Wow,
I'm excited.
So you go and you break the American amateur record right away, first,
first attempt out. And is that when you felt like, fuck I could do this shit?
Yeah. I went home and I told my, my fiance at the time,
we were living in a studio and we were just broke and I was volunteer coaching
and I was, uh, for high school, which is my passion in high school football.
And then I was working at that club at night, so I didn't have a lot of time,
but I was like, I can make this happen. Like with,
with my personality and this is a platform, I can do this.
And everybody kept telling me there's no money in strongman. There isn't any.
And there really wasn't.
There wasn't like there was no money in strong man until I made money in strong
man, like really brought it into.
There was several other people but like what we did was we cultivated a whole
new era of strong men was before like even like Pooja Nowinski was a guy who got
a lot of attention because he looked just shred it. You Know Jack,
but I mean if you, if you,
he's got like a cribs episode that they did in Poland and he's got this tiny
little house with like little knickknacks and stuff he's so proud of.
It's really weird. It's crazy.
But like even then he's five time world's strongest man winner.
There's really no money in that.
I would've thought he would've been balling out of control. You would think so.
Cause I know who he is.
I feel like if I know who you are and you do something on TV, you must be ready.
Exactly. That's, that's the rappers. The display. Yeah.
I'm flying in first class and then you'd catch the little bow in the back. Well,
I remember one of the weird things that I read about putting now skis.
How Much Candy Heats, Huh? Yeah.
And then he really likes a candy in between workouts because he's blowing out so
much sugar than he would eat chocolate bars. I makes sense. We do a lot of like,
I do peanut butter and honey, stuff like that during competition,
peanut butter and honey or snickers bars and I eat peanut butter and honey,
you need a spoon? Like how you usually make the sandwiches?
I see guys just pouring honey in their mouth. Like the Russian guys.
There's a Russian guy who was a Russian secret service for awhile and this Oh
yeah, like you look in his eyes,
you're like this Martin fuckers done some bad things but he's the nicest dude in
the world. He's, he's like the sweetest guy.
He comes like he always comes over and talks to me and my family and he's,
he doesn't speak good English but he's really nice about trying to get his point
across and everything. But um, yeah that,
that guy has done probably scary shit.
I'm sure there's a lot of that cause we compete with people from all around the
world, you know, and you know, we, uh,
we tend to forget that everywhere else, there's a lot of, it's normal almost.
It'll be like that in some places, right. To survive.
And if you're a giant dude, it's probably the best way to make a living.
Exactly. Yeah. So they just squirt honey in their mouth. Yeah.
They'll just port like,
like a whole little canister of honey and just take that,
you see guys do that right before they go lift and stuff. I'm, I uh,
the way I grew up in the, the,
the way I did things like I was always taught and it kind of worked with being
broke, but like a warrior goes to war hungry. That's like in football.
I would never eat before a game ever. And then, um,
got an a strong man and I did that for a long time and I got up to 440 pounds
and I would, I would do an entire show, like five, six hours without eating.
But then during it I would snack a little bit, but I would never eat a meal.
But then the resources and eats up your resources. Right, right. And See,
for me it felt like anything in my stomach just made me feel like slow.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying. Yeah, too. That's the same with comedy too.
And I learned that from Kat Williams,
watching an interview with him just don't eat before you go on stage. I'm like,
that makes sense. Yeah. You're better off being hungry. Right.
Josh do that to the best hunters. They hunt hungry. Yeah. So then,
but what happened to me was I lost 80 pounds.
I was four 40 I lost 80 pounds and when I got hurt in Botswana,
I lost all that way. And just because of the bicep tear. No, I,
I chose to do that. When I graduated high school, I was 370 pounds.
So I'm always been a big dude,
but I got up to four 40 and just walking around it was laborers, you know,
I felt like fucking horrible. How you, when you did that log press,
that log press, that was like, like four 25 ish,
four 30 when I run that. So like I gained a little bit more after that. I just,
everyone tells you in the sport, the bigger you are, the stronger you are.
And that kind of holds true to static lifting. Like kind of,
it's not necessary all the time, but it kind of holds true.
But we've got a movement,
like we're talking about pulling a truck and doing those events and all that
stuff when you're four 40 and your body's not agreeing with that for 40,
it just holds you back.
You know what I imagine the load on your joints to particularly lower back my
little buggies. Yeah. So that's what happened.
I had got hurt and I'd felt like I was done cause my low back, I,
I'd have to take me like 45 minutes to get out of bed in the morning. Really?
Oh yeah. That was messed up man. Really bad. And then an MRI,
I never got an MRI and didn't, I'm scared to
just fucking roll fix it. Uh, when I lost weight, it got better.
And it's core strength for me now. Core strength and stretching.
And also I smoke weed. Like a lot of,
a lot of athletes are against it and a lot of people think that there's some
like negative connotation with being like someone who smokes weed. But I mean,
I'm watching guys take Vicodin like a skittles. I'm watching,
I've seen guys throw away their lives, their families,
their career over a bunch of pills because they didn't want to smoke and it's
crazy, you know?
And we actually officially got world's strongest man to take marijuana off of
the drug testing. Oh wait, wait, wait, wait.
This is drug testing and world's strongest man.
Are they making sure you're on steroids to test you though,
make sure you're strong. They test those kind of bitches.
Not Enough drugs in the scotch system.
Do you know who Robert Frank is the sound familiar? He's a, he's hilarious.
A Instagram guy. I can't recall, but it sounds really familiar. Yeah,
he's, he's really funny, man. He's, he's like, he talks like this.
He's really fast. Yes. Yes. He's got this fucking hilarious rant about, uh,
someone getting the girl pregnant and taking responsibility and he, and he goes,
he goes, I have to ask you. He goes, if you're trying to get jacked in, Dan,
what kind of gear are you
on? I have to question your gear. If you get your girl pregnant,
what kind of swears do you have?
That guy's got so much energy. I know he's another one.
He gets sensored off of Instagram all the time. They pull his posts and they,
he's got a million followers and they won't give him a fucking blue check mark.
That's ridiculous. People understand that. That's our livelihood.
A lot of people that social media is how we feed our fucking family. Well also,
he's fucking funny,
but he's funny with toxic masculinity.
Toxic because his opinions different. When I love,
that's it right there. He's not 10.
If red play that is red. He's funny, man. It's funny,
which I stay the most curious. Okay.
The week x will flow every check out the call you check.
We want a piece of my poll. I want to tell you a story.
I've got a broker who can, I ruined his life.
He said my videos give him the motivation to get you these.
Fuck hey showed up to the bar every weekend. We just got to talking to sleeves.
[inaudible] he doesn't host but different.
Have you coach like fucking boss problem is what I would call them up.
Say she's pregnant now he's blaming me. Fringe reducer to the gate.
First of all,
who the fuck told you to go road talking to if that's how you roll.
There's plenty of other techniques proven.
You get the fruits in the sheets like a sticky belly or sticky lower back.
[inaudible] you get the homes on the side or not.
I've been told since I was four years old, days of old and next football,
it's kind of [inaudible] around the baby's foot protected.
That's what he's saying.
Like don't cut me down to stop that pocket because you never know what you're
going to want the rocket. But when you tell us,
oh the plus stuff on that ass cause I'll Robert fucking frick and I'm the way
that it's put in a men's biggest threat.
I know you had to store it to get some big before. Oh no,
fucking fours crushed up. My pay to floor stepped up
so close to goal, so I should probably take the talk. Oh fucker. Yeah.
It's funny shit man. It's fucking funny shit.
And he can't get a a, he can't get approved and they,
they've gone through publicists. They've tried to get him.
What does it recognize? What is it called? Verify. Verify.
Try to get them verified. Try and get that blue check mark next to his name.
It's silly, man. I'm, I'm, I don't know how that even works.
Somebody who's too big did mine too much muscle. Yeah. I mean,
well you can do it because you're not making fun of things.
He's making fun of things to talk about getting this car pretty strong.
Goddammit. Strong opinion. It's perfect. No, it's,
it's silly that they do that though. You know, it almost, I mean,
if you look historically back, every time they've done that,
those people have got more power. Like all you're doing is feeding that guy.
So in 10 years when you look like the asshole that censored him,
he's going to be 10 times that. Well,
especially now that we're talking about them, which is good. Yeah,
it is good that this exists. It's fucking good. I think so.
A lot of people appreciate it. Well,
I think this is a weird time where you can't, you're,
you're having people dictate what you can and can't see or what is in his value
isn't, isn't valid. And it's just, that seems like nonsense to me.
Like we're moving backwards, especially with something like that.
He's being funny. Like he's funny.
He makes me laugh.
Well, I'll do my jokes. Yeah, we are tough. Fuck man. Even mad jokes man.
Even bad jokes by juice heads. Yes. It's fun. He talks about being a juice head.
It's hilarious. My first introduction to comedy, I loved growing up.
I was a huge fan of Richard Pryor and all that stuff out. Huge fan of,
of Carlin. I just big fan of, I even liked a, what was his name?
Jeff Foxworthy. I Love Fox, which was great. And, um,
my first time I ever got to see a show, I came in,
I move into La and a buddy of mine brought me to see you and uncle Joey and I
was like, holy fuck,
I couldn't first Joe comes out there and you can't even breathe when you just
got, you don't get a second. As I got down
an animal, he's got some shit right now.
Like if you get a chance while you're in town, you got,
he's got some new shit that we were falling on the ground crying the other
night. Oh yeah, I'll come check them out. And he's the best ever. He crushes.
He crushes, I wouldn't know ones like funny or in bursts you might get,
you know guys who are really good joke riders,
guys who are really funny guys who are like, they're,
they're valid in terms of our culture. But no one's funny than Joey D, right?
No, no, no. The whole room, like it was like we were uncomfortable.
We could not stop laughing, you know, so Dan Perry, we are eating.
Then when you went up it was like, so it was, it's a whole different style,
but it's like super like along the way that I think about how like you're
introspective and comparative with different things and stuff and the way you
make people like look at something in a different angle and then you poke fun of
the way that you originally thought about it. You know,
that's at least how that set was. But it was, I mean, I,
being in a live audience is so different than watching a special on TV. Oh yeah.
Better. Well, I met you in the belly room,
which is one of the best places to do stand up were the last tiny room.
Yeah, I did a set of them about, I've been on stage once and I didn't know.
And the, yeah, the belly room. Yeah. I went up there and did the,
it was story time and um, uh, tape Fletcher and uh,
Oh man, I can't remember who else. A bunch of people just kept telling me like,
like, just go up there and tell the story. Just go tell a story. And I was like,
all right, there's no cameras in here. Right. I can tell a real story.
We're having a thought are we talking about, but um,
they got me up there and I did six minutes. They gave,
they gave me four and I ran on for six. I didn't know what the lights meant.
I was just talking, you know, I didn't know.
And I told a story about being in China and we thought we were going to go to
jail in China and stuff and it was fucking hilarious what happened in China that
year. You saw me in the picture,
we got done with world's strongest man and we do like a celebration.
We all go to dinner and all that stuff. And I was,
I was fucking excited cause I was the only rookie in the finals.
I was super excited.
So I'm hammered drunk like in China and then little things start to click.
You see people all wearing like the communist uniform like that they have,
they were celebrating, I dunno if it's called communism day or whatever,
but they celebrate and, and like almost the entire city.
We were in Sonia, which is a little island,
which is like their kind of vacation island. And um, but they were almost,
everybody was dressed in those uniforms. And I'm drunk and like,
I'm looking around, I'm starting to feel uncomfortable and we finally,
we'd get up to go and we all get on this bus.
And the guy who runs world's strongest man is a very old man. He's,
he's gotta be like in his nineties. Right. But he's, he's, uh,
needs help moving around, all that kind of stuff.
We get on the bus and uh,
we're setting up in the camera crew left all that stuff on the front seat,
which is, which is the older guy seat, you know,
and we make sure that he has that seat, you know, and um, we get in,
we're trying to finagle like the nothing [inaudible] we're trying to be
assertive but nice to the the camera crew that they have to move back.
And they were, they didn't speak English at the moment, you know, and they were,
they were acting like they just didn't understand their,
they being really rude about it. And uh, Nick [inaudible],
who's actually on the TV show with me, um,
he came over and he picked up the camera and he was like, you're moving.
And started walking back with the camera case.
And then the guy got up and started yelling at us and English and he's totally
knew exactly what we were saying the whole time.
And he's yelling at us and freaking out. And Nick puts the camera down,
like towards the middle of the bus and then sits back down.
The Guy Marches off the bus, comes back on the bus with three cops,
three police officers and Chinese uniforms and I'm fucking scared shitless.
Like I've heard horror stories about Chinese prison, you know,
it does not sound like the place to be. And the guy,
the guy and the cops are getting really worked up about the fact that he touches
equipment and that Nick's called him an arrogant American.
All this stuff like freaking out and the police officer, literally,
nobody ever believes this, but it was like in 300 almost fucking exactly.
He goes,
this is China and he's screaming at a bus full of the world's strongest men.
He's fucking scared. All of us into thinking we were going to go to jail.
This is China.
And he's screaming at him and nick best like Kinda sits back in a seat and puts
his head down and he realizes like, you know, we better shut the fuck up.
So we all like Kinda tucked our tails in and sat there and then the older guy
got on the bus, took a seat,
then the camera guy kind of pretended like it didn't happen. Went in,
sat back down, the police officers left, but the, in the entirety of that,
that situation, like I fucking, I could've swore I was going to prison.
Scared to death. You do not want to get locked up in an Asian prison? No.
Especially China. No, no, no, no. Not that.
And especially that spot because like it was, it was their vacation island,
but it's fucking dirty.
Like the stories you hear about kids shitting in the streets and stuff.
It's not everywhere in China, but on the island it was everywhere.
Like the kids just stop, pull, open their little shorts and take a shit.
Ari told me, saw that in the mall until people just walk in the mall walking.
They just stop, pull their pants down and shit on the ground. Yeah. And I went,
what on the floor? Yeah. Yup. That's what they do, man. It's crazy.
It's so crazy. So who comes and cleans up the shit? I don't know.
I don't think anybody, when it's outside, there's, there was just everywhere.
Wheeling. Yeah. You see human shit everywhere,
all over the place in the smells like it. And we almost,
I think there was 30 of us, like 26 of us all got stomach flu or stomach,
uh, in intestinal parasites. Oh, I bet everything has got shit on it.
If people are just shitting on the street,
there's probably shit everywhere you touch.
They were burning tires for the streetlights. It was nasty man. What? Yup.
Yup. The island. It's, it's gorgeous too. I'm telling you like the photos,
the pictures Sonia island is gorgeous. Burning Tires for street lights.
Yup. That's, and these motherfuckers want us to switch to electric cars. Yeah.
They're over there burning tires and China.
Well at least in 2013 they walk man days. It's crazy. Crazy.
Where else have you had to travel for strong man? Um, I did, I've done Africa.
Dubai is, is one of my favorites. It's, it's,
it's creepy sometimes like just realizing I don't like not feeling like I'm in
control of what happens to me, my destiny, you know,
so like when I'm in Texas I feel great and I'm like 90% of the people around you
are armed. If some shit happens, they got it.
My girl actually like she rides horses and she managed the gun shops.
Like I'm straight, you know, I don't have shit to worry about.
But like when you're,
when you're in like the Middle East or when you're in China or anything like
that, you just have this feeling inside. You're like,
it could fucking go wrong crack. But uh, when we go to Dubai,
we actually do world's ultimate strong men in Dubai and we're going to do
another competition. They're October 25th, which is,
it's the highest paid strong man show that exists. It's a really big show.
It's a lot of fun. And we go out there and they fucked up.
They gave me the keys to a Ferrari and I just fucking went crazy.
I went through downtown going like one 20. There's also no cops to theirs.
Doesn't have any cops. They might have a few like in certain areas, but it's,
it's basically they use cameras everywhere. So if you,
if you speed or if anything happens or you steal or anything like that,
it's all on camera.
Like there's literally cameras everywhere and that's how their judicial system
works. They don't use police, they just say,
oh well let's look at the camera footage. Exactly.
Locked that motherfucker out forever. Yup. Yup. And when we were there,
like it was craziness going on with the royal family and stuff like it was,
it was pretty tight. I'm going back in October.
I don't know if you could Google it. It's crazy.
You look at that place like what it was like in 1970 versus what it is now.
Like some of the before and after footages. It's insane.
There's so much wealth there. Yeah.
I mean they have built the biggest building in the world.
They're the tallest building in the world. Rich Khalifa.
I Shit my pants at the top of that building. Not Literally, but like
I hate heights and I went up there and like I couldn't walk.
How many floors is it like I'm 30 I don't know man. We get on the,
we get in the bottom of the elevator and Eddie Hall, who's, who's also in the,
in the show with me, it's me, Eddie Hall, Nick Best and Brian Shaw.
First of all, how the fuck is that elevator going to carry all you assholes?
Exactly. We get in, they closed the door to go up and Eddie farts. Oh No.
I was like this motherfucker know 130 something floors smelling this guy's ass.
You know, it was horrible. And Eddie's the worst. He's English.
So he's eating like porridge and she'll drink a tea in fart and I will put tape
Fletcher's farts up against any man who's ever left. Oh my God.
The worst back in the day when he was fighting, he used to,
I think he just over consumed protein and then he was legendary, legendary.
And he would laugh. He would laugh and he'd be like, oh we gotta grind.
Cause you know the fog was coming.
He would laugh first and then it would come up. Jesus, that's the worst.
When they enjoy the fact that you're like, God damn it,
he doesn't do it anymore though. He must've cleaned his diet up.
He's never got me either. Remember I loved,
I loved going out with Tate because like normally when I go out,
especially in la or something,
I just draw away too many weird eyes feel like I just like need to like hide in
the corner. But with Tate it's like the bash brothers walked in. Right.
It's not as big as me, but he totally normalizes me. So awesome.
We still going into the comedy store as my favorite man. I used to go in,
actually I saw a lot of the transition from when you started coming back and I
saw the culture changed. Man, you, you did a lot for that.
So that place fucking changed the entire culture. That back room. That's crazy.
It was awesome man. Well that's my spot. You know,
I wasn't there for seven years. Yeah, yeah.
And you and I was there just before and then just after,
and I used to go in there a lot.
I used to go hang out a lot and I'm telling you, just,
just the way the comedians interact with each other is totally different.
When I first went there it was very like, like, oh well I've,
I've had this and I can do this.
And it was basically like Hollywood at the comedy store, you know?
So like if you're like waiting to audition for a commercial and these,
these people were all telling each other how cool they are.
That's what it felt like. Then now, now, I mean not now.
I haven't been there for like maybe a year or two,
but then after that it became more like,
like what we do like with talking shit to each other and it's like,
it's a camaraderie thing. It's not like I'm better than you.
It's like we can all talk shit. We're all on the same level. You know?
That's very important to me that I think that that it probably comes from
martial arts, but it's also just my, my own philosophies.
Like I want everybody to do good. I don't want to be the only one doing good.
Right. I don't understand that. I've never understood that I want,
I want like when I go on sh elected, go on the road,
I try to bring the best people alive. I want everybody to have fun. I want this.
The audience have a great show. I want people to kill. Yeah.
And I try to help comedians and I really want to support them.
I'll try to get them all on my podcast. I try to tell everybody they're great.
Try to tell everybody to go see him. Yeah.
And will you see what that cultivates too? Everybody got better. Yeah.
I mean Joey probably exactly the same. Now he's, he's a better than him.
He's always put the same part of when Joey became a monsters cause he got all
this love, you know, and realized he could just be himself up there. Yeah.
Like when they stopped taking coke and all that stuff. Yeah. That helped.
But even when he was doing coke, he's fucking amazing. Yeah.
I can't imagine him not the employment I can,
I can hear him tell the same story five different times and still crack up every
fucking time. He's an American original.
There's not a whole lot of people like that guy, so that place, uh, yeah, it's,
you know, it's just insecurity when, when,
when people realize they're loved and that there's real comradery in a,
a brotherhood and sisterhood and that you really do care about each other.
Everybody like that places all hugs man, go there. But he's hugging. Yeah.
And it wasn't that way. I know. I know. Every time I give you a compliment,
I see you kind of like wince a little bit when people like, like,
like yourself or I'm the same way.
Like whenever I do something well and someone tells me, I'm like, Nah man,
I should have done this this way or this.
I'm always that I should want up myself guy.
But you really changed the fucking culture there, man.
And you've made a lot of people better. The same with the podcast, big ops plan.
It was all. Thanks brother. Thank you. Well, I feel very lucky. You know, I'm a,
I'm a very fortunate person, so I like to spread it fucking from,
from where you started to where you are now. The hustle man, that's inspiring.
I always feel like I need to do more and I need to like extend myself in
different areas and stuff. I look at like so many people out there now,
we actually have access to, I mean, you can see like, uh, Jocko,
like this dude's up at four 30 in the morning and I'm like complaining the fact
that I only got six hours with this guy, you know,
like you really learn your level of hustle in reality versus where you put
yourself in your head. You're like, I'm killing it. I'm working so hard.
There's nothing more I could be doing.
And then this motherfucker up four hours before you killing it. But those guys,
they've their fuel, you know, guys like Goggins him, Jocko, those guy,
Cameron Hanes, those guys are fuel. Yeah. Like if you ever start thinking, ah,
maybe I'll slack off. Maybe we'll take a day off.
That's look at Jocko fucking hairy gorilla arm.
But that four 30 on his iron man watch it just says attack. Right?
I was showing someone that today, this a, this lady that at the, uh,
the clinic that I go to, she was, uh,
talking about how her boyfriend's into Jocko. He goes,
she'd go to his fucking Instagram page every morning that you see,
you see that four 30 watch and it's like, fuck, I gotta go. I gotta get go into,
what am I doing? Yeah. It just,
but it really is fueled like you feel charged up when not when I listened to
like Goggins talk.
It's like a lot of soft motherfuckers want you to stay in bed. Fuck that shit.
That shit. You gotta get up and go get attack, stay hard. And you're like,
I'm gonna to stay hard, David. Oh yeah.
Yeah. I love it man. I love it. It's nice man.
It's cool that we actually have that nowadays. Yeah, man,
this didn't exist before. I mean,
you think about before the Internet and podcasts and social media and stuff like
that was, you ended up find that inspiration, right? Hard to find.
And sometimes you'd think you'd have an inspiring person in your life,
but really out in reality, it was just some shit bag.
It was like just close enough that it look like that when you stepped back as an
adult, you're like, oh, okay. Yeah. There's a lot of faking it. Yeah.
A lot of people fake like they work hard. Right.
Actually somebody was trying to tell me the story.
I've heard you talk about it on here, about that guy who pretended to be a, uh,
an MMA like guru or whatever and ended up murdering his girlfriend.
Yeah. Well, no, he murdered his girlfriend's husband. Okay. Yeah.
Someone was pretended to be a black belt and a any rolled with them.
And uh, you know, like when you roll with somebody, there's no faking it.
Like with karate, you can kind of fake it.
Like there's guys that like are athletic and they can throw some kicks,
like just like learning on the streets, just hanging out with their friends.
They know how to throw some kicks.
This is people that know how to throw a wheel kick that I've never taken a
martial arts class in their life. And if you see him throw a kid it's like, wow,
that guy's legit and but you don't know unless you see them actually fight.
So the problem with that is inspiring a lot of karate sparring,
you're kind of polite and you're not trying to hurt each other. He just like,
and you could kind of fake it a little bit,
you could throw some shit in the air and fake it and touch each other.
But in Jujitsu you have to roll. It's, it's,
you know the guys grabbing your arm, arm, drag news, taking your back,
you've got to defend correctly. And Eddie was like, man,
I don't know what the fuck is going on, but that dude is not a black belt.
And I'm like, really? I go like, like, what do you think? He is like,
he's terrible. He's like,
he has nothing that he said he was a CIO before Eddie was deep, deep, deep,
deep, deep into conspiracies. Back then it was like he was barely,
he was like in the UFOs and shit. It was barely any conspiracy.
He's way off the deep end on me and the UFO is,
well, maybe it is true.
I am a,
I'm scheduled to have a phone call today this afternoon with George Knapp.
He wants to brief me on all this shit.
George Knapp is the guy that broke the Bob Bizarre story in the 1990s and you
know, he shares my opinion. He's like, most of this is bullshit.
Most of these people are liars. Most of these people are crazy. Right?
But there's some real shit out there too.
Like a lot of these air force pilots that they have eyes on this fucking thing
that's going 600 miles away in a second,
like dropping down from 60,000 feet to 10 feet, like in a second.
And they're like, I don't know. We don't know what the fuck this is.
We have no idea how these things are doing this. And that's not some hope,
Billy. Like just no talking about Sask. Exactly. Now. Yeah.
It's air force pilots.
People who they're trained to fly jets and have gun fights in the fucking sky.
These are exceptional human beings. When they see things like that, you got to,
they know what the fuck
they're seeing. That's so crazy. Yeah. Who knows?
The thing is like every day you could go out there and look in the sky and you
don't see shit. You go, there's nothing up there because you're not seeing it.
But if you go to a fucking lake, you're never going to see a shark.
You know what I'm saying? Like it's doesn't mean sharks aren't real.
It's like you're looking in the wrong spot or you want,
you aren't there when they show up, but they're real.
So we have enough accumulated data to know that all there are sharks.
You know they are real, but they're not in lakes. They're in the ocean.
Here's where they are. This is how you find them. Go to South Africa. Oh look,
there's a shark. Yeah. Oh yeah.
Or I'm fucking Catalina off of Catalina. I'd shoot you.
I worked at a boy scout camp in Catalina.
I'm just teaching snorkeling and that was like the whole time I was shitting
myself. Oh my goodness. It's just the nicest water in the world though.
It's so warm and salty. You just float. You know.
We did fear factor out there a couple of times. Yeah,
we did a couple of the stunts. My a couple of Waterstones here.
That's a cool spot. We stayed on the other side, like the,
there's the hotels on the one side and everything.
We were on the other side of the campsites. It was awesome. Awesome.
I was like 13 and I got so roasted,
my entire body became one blister. Oh no stupid. I was stupid.
No sunscreen done. None out there. All Day long. Yeah.
So I don't know if you know UFO is real, but it's,
it's certainly believable enough.
It's not like the sky's empty. It was filled with stars.
So do you think now after speaking with him that do you think we've had contact
like that?
It's hard to tell cause they could've been flying on opinion enough for the
listeners. Not for anybody else.
Just you when you're at home and you're chilling, do you think? I don't know.
I really honestly don't know. I couldn't say yes or no.
I'm more inclined now to think there's something going on than I was before I
met Lozar and watched that documentary because I was on the,
not that I was saying that aliens are not real. I think there,
I think there's 100% life out there for sure. Just say that it's too big. Right?
It just doesn't make any sense that there isn't.
It's the question of whether or not it ever has gotten here before is the weird
question.
And it's also the problem is that you feel foolish talking about it because so
many people who believe in it are foolish and so many people who tell stories,
there's their stories are foolish.
So you feel foolish kind of going along with it.
But I'm very careful about stuff like that because I'm like,
just get something makes you feel foolish. Doesn't mean it's true. You know?
It doesn't mean it isn't true. Yeah.
So I definitely think there's a very high likelihood that there's life out
there. And it's entirely possible that something's gotten here before,
but as to whether or not something really has made contact with people.
I don't know. I'm in class. If I would say like where's my scale?
It's like probably 65% believe 35% going.
Especially after talking to that guy. Yeah, he but what he could,
he could've experienced something that was an experimental aircraft that they
didn't want to tell them. Right. You never know man. I mean,
I don't still know what the
tech, look, I'm a moron. Like I don't understand physics at all.
I have no knowledge of propulsion systems or mathematics and I don't know what
the top of the field in propulsion experts are capable of today. I don't know.
They might be some shit that they're working on that they've never really
perfected,
so they've never actually implemented in the battlefield or something like that.
But they have some sort of a drone that looks like it would be filled with three
foot tall people like these aliens that they described. I don't know.
And they're not going to fill you in on that if you think it's alien thing.
Fine. It's fucking alien. Exactly. I mean, who knows what that was. I mean,
they,
they're taking this guy who was a physicist from Los Alamos labs who went to cal
tech and they, they sent them to these, uh,
classes and MIT to learn fucking nuclear shit.
And then they try to see if he can figure out how to back engineer something
they tried to say. That doesn't mean it comes from another world. Right.
It could have been the Russian thing.
It could have been something that the Germans figured out. I mean, I don't know,
but I'm more inclined to believe him than not believe him. Yeah.
He didn't seem like he was full of it, you know. Exactly. Just looking at him,
he also didn't seem like he even wanted to be here. He was just like,
I'm done with this.
And I was getting migraines talking about it before we even got out here.
He was like, I just gotta tell you I'm getting a migraine. And like, you know,
Jeremy was trying to talk them into doing it.
Like we're going to be fine George. I mean Bob is important,
it's really good to do this and we're gonna be able to really get the story out.
But I think more more people told me that they got more out of the conversation
because it's just him talking not no spooky music,
no edits and you get to see like he's honest about what he knows and doesn't
know. And when he would say like, what do you think about this? He's like maybe,
I don't know. Like it wasn't a bullshit, didn't seem rehearsed full of shit.
Nothing. What he was saying, if he didn't believe in that at least to himself,
what he was saying, I I'd be fucking amazed.
And His story has not deviated in 30 plus years, which you can't.
I've tried to have me tell a story of something that actually really did happen
from 30 years ago and I probably told that a bunch of different times what we
started the podcast. It's hard to remember, especially when you,
my memory varies day to day.
Like some days it's awesome and some days it's dog shit.
It's crazy how that works, Huh? Yeah. Have you, you've had a few concussions,
right? Oh yeah, sure. Same here. Yeah. I, I have horrible memory,
but from football it's like probably the worst thing ever for concussions
because you're getting them even from body hits when dudes as big as you are
clashing into each other, your fucking brains getting rattled around in there.
Even if your head doesn't get hit. Right. And I, I played rough,
like I didn't avoid anything, I'm sure. Yeah.
Well that's a strength of yours. A guy as big as you, I mean,
I would imagine you would impose that exactly. Paid for college.
College for, what was the history. History. Oh, that's cool.
You're on the history channel now. No, it was awesome, man.
It's actually the only thing I ever liked about, I never liked in school. My
science and math didn't really click by history. It was all special to me.
Do you listen to Dan Carlin? Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. Of course.
The best hardcore history he needs. I wish he would just do more.
Let's say only go hard. I know the research.
That's where you have to appreciate it. You know,
I'm embarrassed to call what I do a podcast in comparison to what he does. Yeah,
he does. Is like a lecture. What? Yours is the podcast though.
He needs to call his something else. That's what it is. It's way more in depth.
He's his hardcore history on world war two and World War One and the one on the
Mongols, the greatest fucking Shit I've ever heard.
The Mongo one I've listened to like four or five times the wrath of the con.
Fuck. It's good. He's so good. He's so entertaining too.
It's like if history was that entertaining,
we'd have a fucking world full of history scholars and we wouldn't be censoring
Instagram right now. But you people know how that works.
Then it be jumped to 10 put a sock on your cock.
Yeah. Dan Carlin is a, he's, he's a fucking man. He really is.
His podcast is incredible and the fact that he only charges a dollar for them,
you know, and no, no, he did that while he's there free.
And then when you go deep into the archives, he charges a dollar a podcast,
which is fucking nothing. I mean an hour and a half long.
It takes a months and months to do and he's really just trying to make up for
production costs. He's not trying to get rich.
He would recharge him much more than they're worth more. Man.
I've learned more from that than I did from college. You know,
he retain it because he's entertaining. He's the man and he's a great guy too.
I really love that guy. And his story is interesting too.
He's the old time radio guy, you know,
and did radio and then was always a history buff and even says he's not a
historian. He's like very self deprecating. But that damn,
you're probably the most important historian of our time. Exactly. As I,
for guys like me,
I've learned more about history from that guy than probably from anybody. Yeah.
So I mean probably this moment now, he technically is a historian you,
I think we should at least give him that. I mean he's got him. Yeah. I mean,
I don't know what you have to be to be,
I guess a practicing scholar is like his, you say whole new show.
It's official. He's a, he's absolutely historian. Boom. Dan Carlin.
You are a historian. Give that man a plaque, give him a plaque,
give them a piece of paper, some bullshit group of dudes.
One of my favorite things about the TV show is being able to like dive into the
history of this stuff. Like we did a a an episode in England.
We were in London for most of it. And um,
this Guy Thomas toppum and he was a fucking psychopath person,
like just a crazy person. Like he, uh, he,
he owned a pub and his way of getting people in was doing these crazy feats of
strength and he would,
he would go out there and one of the biggest feat of strength, which we,
we challenged ourselves to do and we actually attempted a world record,
I can't say if we broke it or not,
but we took these giant barrels of whiskey out in front of this pub downtown
London and we picking them up on like a yoke.
You know what a yoke is like a yoke walk. Yes. Yes. So like that.
So the crossbar goes across your Mac and you pick up,
basically we went though the world record we were attempting was, uh,
I think it was like 1,790 pounds, something like that. So it was,
it was big. It was big. And in front of a crowd, that's silver.
That's a car that said in 1968, nine, 11. Yeah,
exactly. Engine and everything. Yeah, it was awesome, man.
When we get to tell his story and talk about like that. My favorite, I'm,
my favorite thing we did for the whole season was probably his episode.
There's an old tale that he got drunk one night and back in the day, um,
London police officers had these little huts they would stand in so they could
be out of the weather and they were like on the side of the road, almost like,
like on a, on our house,
but a little bit smaller and they'd stand in there and they basically keep watch
on the street and being, so the rain didn't get on them.
There was the story that he got drunk with his buddies and just to fuck around
with his cop,
he picked one of those up with them inside carrying it down the street and throw
them into an open grave with the graveyard. So we did that. It was awesome, man.
We're running down these back cobblestone streets with this,
like we didn't use the real police officer obviously,
but we'll like with the whole setup on our,
some of us tried to do it on our backs and one was tried to do other ways,
you know,
but like we're running down and all these people were cheering us on is we're
like celebrating this guy,
but basically like dragged the cop down the street and through,
through window graveyard. It was hilarious. Now when you do something like that,
say a stunt like that, how much of a consideration is like when you look at it,
you go, okay, I think I can do this, but fuck, I might get hurt doing this.
Almost everything. Everything's like that. Like, um,
we were with the daredevils last night and evil evil life,
we did a premiere where, um, like it was, uh, an homage to evil Knievel.
The guys, the guy was going to jump a world record jump,
but he actually broke his ankles doing the testing for it. So this,
this woman came out and she, she broke a world record driving through.
They have these platforms set up with like boards on fire and she did 13 boards
that were all on fire, Chiro face first to him.
She was a fucking savage and she was the baddest, I, I'm so sorry.
I can't remember her name right now. But um,
she came over and spoke to me and like,
I'm from Santa Cruz like you hear the way I'm talking right now.
This is how I talk. Like I'm not like super official or anything like that.
And she came over and I was like, so what are you, what are you thinking?
She's like, oh no, Bro. Probably dry likes 30. Put my face to the motherfucker.
I don't know. I don't know like that. I was like, this girl is fucking savage.
I love this. And uh, it was so awesome. Fighter. Jamie, what's her name?
Golden. Vicky Golden. She looks like a regular girl. She's not even a giant.
She's very pretty. She's, she's normal. Like just Nan.
She's putting her face through boards. Yeah. Jesus for crushed.
It was so god that, fuck
man two, that's, that's the boards though. That's the guy who had the,
oh Jesus. Oh my God.
So she just accelerating through these flaming boards. Yup.
Fucking 13 of them. And that's the kid that broke his ankle axle. Hodges. He,
he uh, he got hurt like just like four days before the live show.
Well, evil Knievel man, they put him back together again.
Back when they didn't even know how to put pack people back together again.
He was glue and shit and screws and rubber bands crazy.
And he just kept calling buck.
You ever see like the x rays of evil Knievel's body? I saw him from the show.
I saw a little bit of it or the videos of him like flopping as he was rolling
and you see his ankle go one way in his arm, go the other way,
and I'm just creeps me out, man. Ty was an animal. He just didn't,
I wonder if he was,
I wonder if he would take something before he would go coconut job.
Everybody was on coke back then. I think so. Yeah. It makes sense. Yeah.
What year was that? I'm talking shit. Probably the seventies in the eighties.
Right? It was before 95 everybody was on coke. I bet.
I mean that would be the thing. Do a fucking giant Bob if he wasn't
God. Right, like some some meth type substance. Yeah.
That's what I was talking to them about is basically the same way they look at a
stunt is the way we look at a lift. It's like this.
This could possibly cripple me. This could finish my career, all that stuff.
What do you got Jamie?
When he jumped the Caesars fountains in 1967 he crushed pelvis and femur
fractures to his hip, wrist, and both ankles concussion.
That kept him in the hospital and rumors that he was in a coma for 29
[inaudible] from jot out and kept jumping. Came back. I think it was six months,
right? They talked about this. I can't remember how long it was,
but he was right back out on it. Seeding and find a picture of his x-ray.
I did. It's not that they're super old, so it's not clear yet.
Oh, what it was. I looked for that first and I was just kidding.
He probably wasn't doing any drugs. Just making a joke. I'll say it.
He's doing coke. Probably drinking, doing coke. Having a great time. Why not?
Fuck it. Everybody else did. Yeah, it was, it was, um,
for that, for that specific lift that we did. I didn't really,
that's him at Caesar's, Huh? Hmm. Jesus Christ.
Look how fucking Fox. Let's look too clear to be, oh, I met his son.
I met his son on the set of fear fat. Yeah. Son made it. Yeah. Ooh,
what the front end. That high? Yeah, that's Robbie. Wow.
Fucking crazy at oh dome. Show me. Oh Geez. I was crazy.
He goes little man, this stuff creeps me out. Yeah.
Well it's just weird that that was a thing like when we were kids,
evil Knievel was like the daredevil guy. Like, you know,
like what do you think your evil Knievel, the toys and everything,
man. Yeah. Yeah.
They had that wind up back in that would just shoot them forward.
So you have to look at a lift. Similar to the way they would look at a stunt.
Like it's, there's a high possibility. Right. And,
and everything from where you stepped those cobblestone streets,
that was the scouts part of the, yeah, because the thing itself was,
I think it was like, like 400 something, something like that.
It wasn't like crazy heavy. It was around 400 pounds. So for us,
that's not that big of a deal unless you put your foot wrong with 400 pounds,
then all of a sudden there goes your ankle, there goes your knee,
there goes your Achilles and, and there, the thing is one, once,
once the whistle blows and it's on and we're racing or you're,
you're playing in a sport and then like the fight starts or like the game starts
when the whistle blows, all that Shit's gone. Like the fear is gone,
the hesitation is gone. I'm gonna fucking win. You know,
that's what I'm here for. So that,
that's when you really have to like worry about that.
So like beforehand I'll always walk the course and just like look like, okay,
I wanna I want to hug this corner.
Even if it's going to take me a little bit longer, I'll,
I'll be loose on this corner. Because it's a little bit of a dip, you know,
stuff like that. But you know, I mean, it doesn't always turn out right.
First world strongest man.
Franklin Colombo just destroyed his knee carrying a fridge. They really, yeah.
Which actually changed a lot of the structure of a contracts that we signed.
Now Franco Colombo was in the worlds the first world's strongest man. Yeah.
I believe it was Frankel Columbo. Yeah. Yeah, it was, there was Lou Ferrigno,
um, Franco Columbo and I could Franco,
was this the shorter guy who's turning Ronald, right? Yeah.
He has the guy who used to blow up hot water bottles with his lungs and make him
explode. Yeah. Which is crazy fucking insane amount of lung power.
Yeah. That's like longevity power too.
And that's the kind of stuff I really like.
I can't wait until like I'm done with the sport and I can actually do stuff
that'll make me feel good. Like, you know,
instead of like waking up broken every day, I'll be like, oh,
I can do a little bit of yoga. I like to hike. That kind of stuff. Yeah.
You're looking forward to a normal life. Yes, exactly. What,
what injuries have you had? Um, I, the first, uh,
the amateur show was doing, I actually,
I competed Brian Shaw who was on the TV show with us.
He's four time world's strongest man when they're out of Colorado.
He was hosting an amateur show in Colorado and I,
I was in Santa Cruz training ocean sea level and went up to outside of Denver to
compete at the show and fucking had a heart attack. It was so, so hard,
but uh, it was the deadlift. It was, it was like maybe
two, two months after I started done lifting, maybe three months.
So I'd never really dead lifted and we were dead lifting a car,
the back end of a car and they made it heavy. So it was probably for amateurs,
heavy is about like a hundred 840 pounds, something like that. So I'm,
I'm winning the show and, and I'm doing it in front of four time.
World's youngest man who already, I had my sights on him like I was coming from,
you know, like I, that's like when I first started I was like, okay,
this guy's the best, this guy's the best. I'm coming for that guy. So I wanted,
I wanted to show out, you know, so I go out and I pull the car up.
I do the first rap and I was like,
just basically it took 90% of everything I had for that first rep,
but like a meathead. I was like, oh, I'll pull the second one, you know,
it's four reps, so I go pull the second one about halfway up my,
my lower back pops and I just let go.
My both of my legs went stiff and then they went numb completely.
I fall forward into Brian's arms actually as he's judging me and my legs were
numb
like maybe two months straight and then off and on for like two years.
They were just so bad for the, for that first two months,
I actually ended up in second finish.
That show ended up in second place qualified for nationals,
which was my goal so I could get my pro card. I went home,
started training for nationals with numb legs and had to sleep in my pickup
truck cause I wouldn't, I couldn't lay down. And we had,
we had a studio at the time, no chairs. We just had a bed.
And so I would sleep in my pickup truck, get up, drive to the gym,
go train and looking back like yeah, that was stupid.
It was really stupid.
But that's once I'd failed at football in my eyes,
I'd failed once. Once I kind of painted myself in this corner, I was like,
I'm just, I'm just not gonna lose. And you never got an MRI? No,
I didn't have insurance. Now you don't want to get a look.
See I kind of do. I mean it feels good now.
I mean I should take a peek. I needed,
I'm going to go get my achilles checked out. Cause at this current,
this last world, strongest man,
I had a decent pop in my Achilles and so I'm going to get that checked out.
But I've been, been really careful about how I, uh, Rehab stuff like that.
But you're right. Yes. I should check out my bag.
It's crazy though that your legs were numb for two years. Yeah. Off and on.
There were straightened them for about two months straight and I'm like,
someone could stab you in the leg, like, like asleep like that. Yeah.
And it was psychotic. It was,
I pinched my side cause I wasn't sure what I was told. And so, you know,
I'd figure that out that then, um, after that I'd,
I was in Africa and I ripped my a bicep off the tendon and um,
I'd been getting beaten up a lot at that point in like my first year of world's
strongest man. It was so easy for me to get to the finals.
I kinda just was like, you know, fucking, you know, whatever.
I know I don't have to work for this.
I am the strongest man without having to work for you.
And then got an Africa after being beaten up a lot and kind of getting my head
pushed down in the sand for two years in a row and rip that off.
And I was just like, I'm done. Like I in my head, like I just,
I had thought I was done.
I remember walking out by the river and sitting there and just feeling like
broken,
just like I didn't know what I was going to do with myself or anything like
that. And I walked back to the tent and the, the referees were telling me like,
you know, get your stuff. They don't,
they don't want you that once you get hurt,
they have to fly you home right away. They,
they don't let you stay and watch the finish or any of that shit. They,
they make you leave. Yeah. Hi. I think it's a liability thing. I don't know.
Basically they just gotta get rid of you. But, uh, the, the,
the judge for the show was like, hey, we're doing the,
what's called the Hercules' hold and, and you're up, are you going to do it?
And the Hercules' hold means you reach,
you reach out with both arms here like this and um, you have like a,
a handle, like basically like a, like in the gym,
you know the row handles like that attached to a tower that's falling and you
hold it as long as you possibly can. And uh, and my mind, I was like,
this is the last time I've ever going to be here,
so I might as well leave some fucking blood on the bar.
So I've walked out and did it. And a torn bicep off the bone. Yeah,
10 the tendon. So I went over there and I was just like, fuck it. Like let's,
let's at least leave a mark, you know, I'm like, I had to do something.
He just tape it up or anything that, what are you going to tape up?
I mean like it's like fully extended your arm.
It's basically just taking weight, pulling you. And so it's not direct,
like curling hurting,
but it's yanking a tendon further up into your bicep.
And I felt that creeping up into my shoulder as I was doing it. And I,
I did great. I actually, uh, it was the best event I'd had that year. You know,
I had crazy rusty and I remember just closing my eyes and being gone and just,
if when I let go, it was almost like being baptized man.
Like I felt like all the pain and all the stress,
everything I'd felt like build up once I'd gotten hurt, I just dumped it all.
And then it took me, it took me a, I think it was two more years.
I finally fought back. I had thought I was done.
And then last year I made it back into the finals. I was,
I'm now again top 10 strongest man in the world.
And so it was because of surgery and Rehab Surgery,
and then everything else was so beat up. Once I, once I finally stepped back,
I was like, oh,
like there's no reason I should have to take an hour to be able to walk in the
morning. And I'm like,
there's no reason why my back should hurt from walking from the front door to
the car. You know,
like I was so racked and so I just started working on different things.
I'm trying to take care of myself and I got back to worlds. Um,
that next year actually I got back and I just didn't do well cause I hadn't been
able to do anything. And then, uh, came back the following year,
which was just this last year. And uh, you know,
basically I'd been written off. It was, it was,
I was told it was my last time I was getting invited because at this point like
you're done, you know,
like it's time for you to find something else and came out and I,
I've had the show in my life, I've been working so hard,
but you never know how strong you are until you line up.
You never know like what kind of athlete Char until you get tested. So I got,
I lined up and I'm, I got done. I just crushed when I'm,
when I finished, I loaded out the stone and I knew I was in the finals.
Like, dude, I get emotional just thinking about it right now.
Like it just felt like somebody had just washed all that away. Wow. No,
I remember ripping my shirt off. I am a fucking show man. I'll tell you that.
I had my strong,
I'm pretty sure underneath and I ripped my world's strongest man shirt and
showed my strong and pretty shirt and I was just roaring and we were in in
Malaysia and like everybody just kinda like stepped back a little bit.
It was awesome.
What kind of stuff does he do to try to Rehab your body to start to get your
body back into condition? Tons of Cowork,
tons of stretching and like basically just digging out scar tissue is huge.
It's huge. Like a lot of people use like a third gun and stuff like that.
I went the cheap route. I took a black and decker skilsaw and I,
I've got this stuff. Attachments, put it all together cost me like 65 bucks,
you know, but like stuff like that.
I kind of figured it all out as I was going. You know,
there's people out there that were telling us stuff,
but it wasn't as easily accessible when I was, when I was first going.
And now like literally now we have a website called starting strong man.
So like people who want to train and figure out like what's a safe way to start
out or like if I want to train like this but I don't want to,
don't want to buy all the equipment to, or if I just,
or if I do want to be the strongest man in the world or if I just want to know
what kind of type of lifts to use to,
to like keep your back healthy to help you use your upper back instead of your
lower back when you're pulling that kind of stuff. I mean it's all there now.
Like literally that that did not exist and you just have to like listen to like
the sock on the cock guy in the gym telling you what to do. You know?
That's what it was for me.
Like it was a bunch of older lifters and I remember just warming up as for
pussies and all that kind of shit. Oh yeah. Old School lifting man. Oh,
it's gonna listen pussies. Yeah.
You ever see a lion warm up before it chases a gazelle?
I've heard that nonsense before. Hamilton was talking that crazy. It's crazy.
It's crazy. I'm not allying and I'm not going after like zone. Yeah.
If you have to, it's there. But if you want to take care of your body,
it's definitely better to warm up. Yes, exactly. Yeah. If you watch like a guy,
I like
Manny Pacquiao train like d. And. T.
I watched him a workout once with a Freddie Roach and he wa he warms up for a
long time. Yeah.
It's like 1520 minutes of warming up.
They said that about Ali that Ali would warm up for one hour. Yeah.
So an hour of his workout was him just warming up his body,
just moving,
moving along and getting stretching and rolling his arms and his legs and
rolling his hips. And then once that blood flow and then he starts shuffling,
now he starts hitting the bag and then he starts hitting the pads.
That's more the older I get, the more I realize how important that is and
like how important it is to teach the next generation how to warm up.
Even just rowing your hips.
I only started doing that in the last year and a half. That's crazy. It's crazy.
It's crazy. Like I put all that strain on my hips and low back. My,
I'm telling you forever and didn't even move my hips in the circle.
Like for your low back. Do you ever use a reverse hyper? I do.
I use the reverse hyper. Um, I like to do a lot of stiff leg stuff.
I avoid dead as much as possible, but I, I mean I still compete. I can't.
And what I did now was, what a lot of guys do is they use a suit.
I didn't know like everyone was using deadlifts suits and it was actually
protecting the low back. And that's a lot of what is dead lifts.
Who does is transfer it to your upper back, which is like,
I went to worlds this year and it was the first time I didn't zero the dead lift
at world's strongest man. I pulled it up and it was,
it was fucking easy and it was, I was in my groups and I was cruising zero.
The deadlift like didn't get a z like a no rep. Like I,
the first time I actually pulled the deadlift rep at world's longest man,
every year I've been fighting to get in the finals and doing my best with one
arm tied behind my back because when this event comes, I get zero points.
But like I finally figured that out. That's what I was,
I was still thinking that I was close to retiring even though I was feeling
better.
But then I realized that I'm so much stronger now and I don't have all the pain.
So like I'm, I'm almost at like peak age for strength too. So I,
I, I've got to give it a couple more years. I get some peak age for strength,
they say, but for, at least from what I've been told,
they say it's like between 34 and 36 is for strong men.
This is what I've always been told,
but honestly I think the longer we study this stuff,
the more realizing is like if you treat your body right,
you can keep getting stronger as long as you don't break things, mess things up.
That's the big issue, right?
People break things and they have to work around those things and they break
something else and they're compensating because one knee's fucked up and then
the other knee blows out because it's compensating for the bad name. Yeah. Yeah.
I was always tell people like,
I know a lot of people that have had ACL surgeries and they try or ACL injuries
and they try to not have surgery. They try to just rehab it and I'm like,
God damn, it just didn't get the fucking surgery. Right. Yeah.
You're going to be out for six months, but at least you'll have a fixed knee.
Yeah. Yeah. You'll be great in a year's can happen whether you like it or not.
Right. And this way that year happens and while it's happening, you know,
you'll realize like, hey, I gotta, I gotta keep my fucking legs strong. Right.
I gotta keep all those stabilizer muscles strong and then everything else
doesn't fall. Yeah, the hamstring, hamstring strength. It's big,
huge. And but strength, a lot of guys don't like to do like butt exercises.
That's huge man. It saves you a low back. It makes you feel better.
And also stretching out the,
the front end of your hips and your abdominals stretching that stuff.
That company you've spoke about him. Yeah. So they actually just,
they hit me up the other day and they were like, we got,
we really want to send you one of these. And I was like, fuck you. I have them.
Do you want one? No,
no, they're sending me one. So we got, I want to give you right now. Nice. Yeah.
Give us a box of them. Give given to people. Fucking believe in them.
They're not expensive. It's real simple. Super easy to use.
I put them down on the ground and lie on it and it just like kits in there and
dig in. It's not just for the Saas Muscle, it's for your whole back. Right.
I use it on everything. I use it on my shoulders. I use on my legs.
I saw a video where this guy was doing the outside of his leg and everything
with a fucking brutal, but you know what's my favorite is that Tim Tam thing?
That thing right there. You see that? That Jack Hammer motherfucker there. Yeah.
That's like a upgraded thera gun. That's like even more powerful ones.
Yeah, that thing's amazing.
And they don't die as quick to a lot of the guys that world's used. Those,
those are good. They're so good.
Although all that kind of recovery stuff is so important guys.
I think they just work out and not take that time and recover.
I was that guy though, learn. I mean I, when,
when I needed, when this ripped, um, we, this, uh,
was the full toe finally, like my, my tendon exploded. It didn't rip actually,
and it exploded. So there was still that when you were doing the Hercules thing?
No, no, that, that was after, cause that was after.
So when that happened it wasn't, it didn't fully separate. So, but when,
when I went home and I was training down the road,
this was like a little while later. So you didn't even get surgery immediately.
He couldn't, you can't. Why? Because first off,
if it's a muscle or if it's not completely separated, you can't get surgery.
But this basically what I'm saying is exactly what you're saying.
Just a different time period. I, uh, I, this exploded off the,
the tendon when I was doing a world record attempt for an axle in training and,
um, that I, I was like, I knew it was tour right away,
but we had the pilot for the TV show. We were supposed to film the Nova Scotia,
Canada the next day. And I knew what an opportunity it was. So I said,
fuck it.
I went and took a shower and got on a plane and I flew to Canada and in Canada
with, with it completely torn,
knowing that I needed surgery and it hurting like, like the worst pain ever.
We had to flip a boat.
So like one of those little rowboats we had to flip it like a tire.
Then we carried 300 pound water jugs up a hill.
We did like all this stuff with that separated and the entire time it just felt
like someone was stabbing me with a cattle prod. Uh,
but that one that was me that, but
where that you were doing more permanent damage though? Not on the BICEP. No.
Once, once the bicep goes,
the only thing worse you can really do is shove it up higher.
So they have to flay you deeper when they pull it down and lays a hard word.
I'm thinking of some fucking inquisition type torture device. Right.
But I had a, I had a great surgeon. I was, I was taking care of man and um,
it was, it wasn't too bad. How long is the Rehab? Two Mill?
Oh, no, no, no.
Three weeks in a cast and then like he gave me this like a,
an arm brace that would like,
I'd adjust it every week or so to where I go more and more straight.
And then that was maybe three months before I could use it.
And at that point it's not like I could go do what I was doing at that point.
You start over and it was, my arm was like tiny,
but I was pretty pissed off. Well even your arm tinies probably go,
yeah, fuck it. But how weird is that?
I'm walking around like with one on like this and the other one was like,
it works like some ID company. Well you know boss Rutan do you know? Yeah,
I've met them a few times. Has, what do you call his baby arm is one arms.
It's small because of atrophy. Because of pinched nerves. Right. This is really,
it's really kind of fucked up. Yeah. Like to this day he,
I don't think you can hold up a jug of milk. Oh Shit.
He couldn't like hold the jug of milk in his arm and extend his arm. Yeah.
That's a guy that for some reason didn't get a lot of the love that he so
deserved. Pioneer savage. Yeah. And one of the most, uh,
like one of the original technical strikers taking on dudes way bigger than him
and still handled them like hoist Gracie is amazing and savage.
But he was doing the exact same thing. Oh yeah. Yeah he was just years later.
But if boys had to fight boss route and it would have been ugly.
But the thing is like in the early days,
boss didn't understand submissions either.
So hoist would have probably got him if it was like UFC one, who knows,
you know, it's um,
it's a crazy sport and the people that have been able to like pave the way,
like a guy like boss route and they were such actively
savage, he would just shoot cortisone and everything.
All of his joints are all fucked up cause he would just take cortisone shots to
shoot it into everything. Wow. Lidacain shoot lidacain into his shins.
Oh my second fucking blast. People not feeling,
he said he was such an animal. He had amazing stories though.
We went to his gym, we did a,
I did Moss Russ moss wrestling is like an old Russian style of wrestling while
you have like a a stick and you each hold the ends of the stick and try and take
it from each other. And um, we actually, I, I did it twice and um,
two tournaments and I was the undefeated American champion for a year and a half
after doing it twice.
But we went to his gym to do the qualifiers to go to the world championship in
Dubai and he came out there and he was judging and stuff and I remember like,
I basically, I was way bigger than most people and I'm,
I'm like upper body heavy,
so I just lean back and take it and at the end of it he walked over and he goes,
uh, he's like, the force is strong with your son. Like I fucking love this guy.
Yeah. He's got a great personality. He's a, he's a great commentator too,
was great at that. It's fun. He makes shit fun. Yeah. He seems like a cool dude.
What's the average lifespan in terms of like how much time you can compete at
the highest level for strong man. Cause it seems like you're,
everything is just so fucking heavy. It's, everything's gonna almost blow out.
Right? Like how many years can a guy
expect to compete at the highest level? Depends on the guy. Depends.
We're getting better at holding onto that kind of stuff.
And if you make it to the top echelon so that you're saying at the top level,
um, I'd say the average, the average is low. It's probably like a year,
two years.
But if you just took the last five years and kind of cut that out and did your
own like, like study that with that five years,
I'd say guys now are going to average more like,
like three to five years. Five maybe six. If you're doing good,
but then you have these guys like,
like Brian Shaw's been doing it since before I even knew what it was. You know,
Brian Shaws four time, world's strongest man and out of Colorado.
He takes his rehab seriously. He's, he like,
he doesn't care about how much it costs or what it takes.
Like it's to him, he's an athlete first.
So like he's got these really amazing like cold pools and hot pools,
rent actually each other at his house.
And then all the different types of equipment that he would need to rehab.
And he's, he's always making sure he gets body work done two,
three times a week. And when we're on the road, like,
like when we were on the road for me that that's, that was, it was an education,
cause I was with nick best, who's, who's 55 and he's,
he's still doing this really, eh,
55 how he's a just a savage man.
He's an old power lifter and he's at the point where he needs help to get down
to the ground, to pick something up where he's trying to figure that stuff out.
And, and he's definitely gonna pay for, for the years of savagery for sure.
But we got, we have him and then we have Eddie Hall,
Eddie Hall's one world's strongest man,
2017 and he's the the strongest person to ever dead lift in the world.
He pulled 500 kilos from the ground, which is 1,104 pounds, I believe.
500 kilos deadlift, just straight split up with it. Like it was nothing.
Looked around the crowd, made sure they understood,
he had it like it was easy and then put it back down.
You know that and a lot of people's opinion that makes him the strongest man
ever to live dead lift to a lot of people as king.
And then we have Brian Shaw four times world's strongest man and he's,
he's like a mad scientist with the stuff.
Like if you go to talk to Brian Shaw about like the trajectory of,
of a sandbag or, or how,
how you want to put your hand placement or where you want to do this or that.
Like anything that has to do with the science of lifting, he can dissect it.
Like basically Bill Nye the science guy. That's what,
that's what I always call him. Is that a Debo, cause he gets crazy,
reminds me of Debo from Friday and he makes me look small.
Brian Brian's got me by like two inches and like 40 pounds. Wow.
And when he gets tired or hungry, he starts to get that flex, you know?
And he's like, like cause like that Debo calm down.
But like I'm traveling the world with these guys and I'm,
I'm basically picking my little pieces out of what they've learned and what
they've done. Cause I'm, I'm very young in this game.
I've haven't been doing it for a long time. I've, I'm still,
I mean I'm getting to the point now where I feel comfortable calling myself like
not a
rookie. I wouldn't say I'm a vet, I'm right about that. But I've,
I've got to learn like what Brian does for his Rehab,
how many times he gets massage therapy and what the differences between massage
therapy and a massage or,
or someone who's a PT and someone who actually is fluent in like deep tissue or
sports, sports therapy, that kind of stuff. You learn all that stuff.
And I never took the time or spent the money. Honestly I just, I never had,
I was never in a situation where I could spend that money and take care of
myself that way.
It always kind of seemed like a luxury and it's not like for them it's
maintenance. It's like getting the oil changed on your car.
Do you roll out with a Lacrosse Ball? Like you use like one of those wad balls.
He was a softball, a softball,
softball because it's big and it's not hard like a baseball.
So I mean for a lot of people that's too much.
But for me it's perfect and I actually do a lot of,
I try and get a lot of people to do them on the front of their hips too.
Cause it's, it's nice like pressure point stuff really good. Or like a,
an atlas stone. The, the, the balls that we lift, the concrete stones,
you just roll your stomach over that and just relax and just let it sit there
and it Kinda just pushes everything back and moves it around.
So I like doing a lot of that stuff.
I've seen a lot of guys do that with kettlebells as well. Yeah.
Down on them and roll it over your back cause it's an unforgiving and it pulls
all the tissue apart. Yep. Exactly. Yeah. Now what about food?
Like what kind of Diet are you guys on? Uh,
we all basically the exact same thing. You know,
just a ton of meat and rice and we do a lot of peppers and stuff like that.
No one's Vegan. No, no, no, no. They,
there was times that one guy that Patrick with the fuck's his name.
There's a Vegan strong man I've heard of. I don't remember his name,
but he's not like, he's never been the world's strongest man. Well there's,
there's a documented they doing with James Cameron where they're trying to
promote him as being, James Cameron is on this Vegan kick.
His wife has a school and they feed the kids all Vegan food.
And Arnold's a part of this too. And they're, yeah, that guy. Yeah. Yeah.
I know who that is. He's, he's not one of the strongest men in the world.
He's a strong man and he's strong. And I've seen no disrespect. I'm not,
I'm not, I'm not saying anything bad about him,
he's just put that back up again. Jamie, he's just a, he's, I don't,
and from what I recall, he's never even been invited towards strongest man.
So it's bullshit. Yeah.
I mean you can say a lot of things like this guy say say he broke a record and
in like a some power lifting competition that was in a guy's backyard. Right.
And they call that a world record and then all of a sudden now he's a world
record strength athlete because his buddy in his backyard said, so the,
a lot of that happens. I don't know specifically about him. I've no,
no clue where he's getting his, his uh,
his credentials from one Neil at day two. This is ridiculous.
One meal a day and Vegan,
Vegan professional powerlifter two 13,
2013 set the deadlift world record for his weight class. Oh, okay.
672 pounds for four. How much does he weigh though? There's six.
72 isn't even big for guys that are like 150. Well, he's only five. Seven.
Okay. So he's smaller than me. So they're there talking about power lifting too.
So once you get into power lifting,
there's so many little federations and stuff like that.
Everybody in their mother has world records and just this and that.
And so does he's documentary is touting, cause that's what I was confused.
Like all the strong men that I've seen are giants, right? Like how,
how can a five, seven guy,
cause I've never seen them anywhere on the circuit or anyway.
And there is a circuit with firms circuit with guys like you.
We have John Sha, Eddie Hall and Nick Best.
We have giant humans. We have the, we have giants live drawing slides,
the qualifying tour for world's strongest men. So to get to giants live,
you either there's like a bunch of little federations that you could possibly do
well in, in that limb bite you or um, you know,
like getting invited is kind of like a,
the only tricky thing getting in. But once you get there,
if you prove yourself and you get top three,
or if if like say you go to my first giant slide, if I went to,
it was like stacked,
like it was 10 of the strongest men on the planet and normally giant's live has
like three of the top 10 and then a few of other guys trying to get in.
And so when I went,
it was top the all the top 10 guys and I got a six place I believe,
but I still got a mud at the world's strongest man because it was the top 10
strongest men in the world there when I did that.
So normally you have to go to a giants live, prove yourself there,
and then you get invited to world's strongest man. And sometimes, uh,
like we've had years where we'll chunks, man got pushed and was filmed early,
so they had to invite other guys. But you can, you can always tell who's strong.
Like you, you can see when a guy shows up and he's ready to go.
Or if he's just got show muscles or if he's just a big chubby dude, you know,
and it's, it's, I mean,
you strap a guy to a truck and tell him to pull it 30 meters.
You're going to figure that shit out real quick. Yeah,
I can only imagine it's a shit show for some people.
Well they see the James Camera thing.
They're pulling this guy out as if he's some world record power lifter,
strong man guy. He probably has a world record.
He probably has some type of world record. I,
I've seen him because I've posted videos talking about my,
my meals and stuff before. And a lot of people give me that, like,
this guy does this and he's Vegan. But I've, I,
I mean if the biggest pulleys ever pulled a six 27 that,
that wouldn't even do like,
that would get last place at an amateur heavyweight show in America.
Because also the other thing is America, we have,
we have the strongest man in the world to like everyone. It's weird.
In America we have these, uh, people like, um, have these,
this love for other countries. Everyone wants to be like,
well I hear in Iceland they're really strong or oh in Poland they're this and
it's like motherfucker, we're strong here. Like we're fucking strong.
If you're an American, getting into worlds is the hardest way to get in.
If you go to another country, it's much easier,
much easier because here we've got,
out of the top 10 we've probably got four or five guys,
four or five guys that are top 10 in the world at any given time.
And only like three or four,
maybe five guys get invited every year from America. So if you're,
if you're getting in the worlds,
you gotta be a bad motherfucker or go move to Poland or actually pull into got a
bad dude right now. Go, go, move to Lithuania or go go somewhere else.
And they would be easier cause you would represent a country with a smaller
town. Much easier went bang out here. I believe that sir.
What about the mountain? The guy from the game of the mountain. From Iceland?
Yes. Legit. He's a salvage Jay. Yeah, he won last year. He's no joke, man. He,
he, he's strong. How'd he say his name? A hassle. Julius. We wants him
just call him Thor. Say it again. Half Thor. Julius Bjornsen. Half Thor.
Julius Brunson. Bjornsen. Yeah, he's a savage.
He's, he's strong and he, he's definitely legit. No joke. You know, he's,
he's good. He got third place this year. He's a, you know,
isn't he fighting off bell's palsy or something? He had,
he had bell's palsy a couple of years ago and um, he's,
I think he's almost all the way better. Like it's not to be rude,
but his face all was, had like a little bit of a, like my,
I've got these huge fat chubby cheeks, so I'm allowed to talk shit I guess.
But he had, he had kind of like that look on his face a little bit already.
So I'm pretty sure he's, he's probably like, oh,
I'd say at least 99% done. And the other thing is that Shit,
a lot of times it's stress. It can be an infection. I, I'm, I'm,
I'm not a doctor, I'm just putting out a doctor at the moment.
I'm working on getting my license chimney.
What the fuck is this guy here for? This fucking guy.
So all of you basically you're saying eat the same thing.
It's just meat and rice. Basically meat and rice. Potatoes.
It's kind of meat and a lot of times it's bison and um,
we do sound strong. Yeah, I fucking love it. I love Bison. Shit.
How long you town for? Uh, two more days. You got somewhere you can cook?
Yeah, I got a lot of elk. Boy. Oh my God. I love you.
My favorite commercial freezers in the back. Nice. I shot two last year,
so I really, yeah, I tried to give it out to as many people. Nice.
Where'd you go? One of them in Utah and one of them in central California.
Nice, Nice, Nice. I've always in Oregon they got a ton of El Con, the war.
It was the Roosevelt elk and in Oregon they're bigger body to right animal and
um, the best meat it is, in my opinion,
the best meat there is his elk by far. It's my favorite.
So good for you too. Yeah, it's tastes so damn good too.
I've never had elk that I didn't like. Even if the guy cooking it sucked,
it still came out good. Yeah. That's a crazy taste. Right.
It's like people that think that a, that venison is Gamey, like first of all,
just because someone hasn't prepared correctly and they didn't take care of it
after they killed it. But too, it's like not elk. No, no.
That shit is always good. You gotta have a old bowl,
like a fucking 10 year old bull has been rotten and stab another Elkwood his
head and it still tastes delicious. When you cook it, it's fucking amazing.
The reason why wolves are chasing those motherfuckers. Exactly. It's delicious.
You don't know what's going on. So how many times do you eat a day? She,
right now it's usually, it's usually about five,
but right now my five meals are smaller. Like when we're going into worlds,
like the last two months,
I mean those five meals and then anything else, everything else just gone crazy.
Everything I possibly can. And um, you know, I try and keep it clean,
but you just, you just want it all in one and everything.
When you're in a competition, how many days is a like a world's strongest man?
Competition? Well, strongest man's normally, uh, two or three weeks.
Two or three weeks. Fucking savage. Brutal.
So are you working out at all while that's going on?
Are you just doing the events?
You're doing the event and then you immediately try and find someplace cold?
Because normally worlds is in some exotic location that we're selling tourism to
. So it's like Malaysia, Africa, we were in Florida this year.
It's all a, some hot, humid place.
So they're trying to get people to come to see it.
A lot of it's a tourism ad and um, it's always beautiful background, right?
The background fucking hell on us, you know, it's brutal. Yeah. So,
but I mean it's, it's part of what pays for everything and none of us really,
we all know to expect it's gonna be hot and humid. We just,
you now myself, this is the first time I've had people come with me.
Like every time I've been to worlds before,
it was just me and my gym bag and I'm just ready to Bang, you know?
But now for some reason I kept thinking of the sock on the cock thing when
we're ready to bang here.
So, but now this, this year and every year forward from now on, I had my crew,
like my girl was with me and uh,
two of the guys I train with and they basically,
so we'll be in our tent and like 400 yards away,
his them lifting and if I want to know who's doing what or what position they're
in or like I'm competing in a group of five,
I need to know how many points this guy just scored, what this guy has.
Like I need to know all that before I would have to walk out there hot and
humid, find out that come back and be moving back and forth,
doing all that stuff if I wanted to get food, anything.
It's just a ton of extra stress this year.
Like they literally wouldn't even let me bend over to tie my own shoes. Like,
like they put them on me, had me set and I was, I was fucking strong as shit.
Joe, I'm telling you because of that everything like the work too,
that I really thank Brian, nick and Ed for, for how strong I was this year.
Like just training with them and then, you know, when you,
when you're with somebody like you compete, let's just, let's just,
if you and I were walking into the door, I'd try and get there faster, you know,
just the way it is. Right, right, right. So doing that for the entire year,
going in the worlds,
I showed up and I've been going chest to chest with the strong, in my opinion,
Brian Shawls, the strongest man who ever lived.
And so I've been going chest to chest with this dude all year.
You 30 other dudes and shit. Like, I'm, I'm here to take your money. Right,
right. So it, I felt great and having them help me and stuff, it just,
it all added up to me feeling the best I've ever felt.
Do you do a lot of ice baths? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I didn't before cause I,
I was basically just posting out and just didn't want to. But they, they,
you have to, if you're training with these guys you have to,
they're not going to let you slide. It's like that, that coach that's just like,
Yo you don't want to go. Okay. Well twice as long for you.
When do you do the the ice bath? Because I was reading something. Um,
I think it was Andy Galpin had a study that he'd put up about a hypertrophy and
how it um, how it affect his,
it's affected by ice baths and that there's a certain amount of time after
lifting you should wait before you get in an ice bath.
We've all known that for a while.
I didn't know that that was new information cause a lot of people are just now
finding out the way your body reacts after a workout. Like the pain,
the inflammation, all that stuff. You're supposed to allow that for how long?
For us it's like we'll train normally it depends on filming. Like,
cause we'd worked 13 hour days on top of that, you know, and you know,
filming us fucking exhausting. It's like, yeah, you did that. Perfect.
Do it three more times. You know, that shit's so crazy. But um,
so normally if we train in the morning, we would,
we would wait to ice best to the end of the day. But if,
if we trained immediately after, um, after set, like we got off set,
we went and train. So it'd be like six or seven at night, we'd come back,
we'd eat and we'd like conversation,
take our time and then we would go just before bed. So it's like,
I think minimum we would do like, like, uh, two hours or so.
And I know maybe that's too long, maybe, maybe. But um, you know,
for us that's usually just, that's our routine.
We don't want to avoid that stuff cause that's Kinda your body learning how to
deal with that. Yeah.
I think that what they were studying was the difference between someone who did
it immediately after a workout or someone who waited an hour and a waiting an
hour was beneficial to muscle growth. Right. Yeah. And it's the same thing with,
you see people like popping Ibuprofen after workouts and stuff and it's like,
Bro, you're supposed to feel that you're supposed to feel that shit. Yeah. Yeah.
That's part of the part of the whole thing.
Now when you're eating these five meals a day,
do you have like a meal prep person that sets it up so the have the right amount
of calories and nutrients and you're doing it like that?
I don't have to worry about that too much. Um, when we're on set,
we have caterers and stuff, so it's, it's super easy to do.
The cater is like give you bison and rice and shit. Like, oh,
it's everything you need, everything we need. It's nice. So when,
when it's that it's not easy, but when I get home, so you get used for that too.
So you go home and you try and eat some shitty meat after after like three
straight weeks of clean food, your body is like, what are you doing bro?
You know, enjoy these parts. Exactly. Exactly. Run my girl out of the house.
They'll get bad drink. What do you drink? Do you drink? Just water, stray water.
Um, uh, I switched to those like uh, we, when we're doing like humid shit,
like we're in human areas of liquid ivy. We did those, we did those.
But W W and I got off of Gatorade and switched to those body armors cause like I
was body almost like less sugar and it's just, it's way better,
more electrolytes. So it's only,
I only do those when when we're actually training and it's human.
I try the best I can to keep myself from like a allowing that type of stuff
unless it's competition. So like when it's competition,
take the fucking Ibuprofen, drink the body armor, all that shit.
Like this is what you, this is the moment you worked for.
Like you want it to be as smooth as possible now.
But when you leading up into that, it's, it's, it's water. Like when I'm,
when I'm really tight on my diet,
like every once in a while it'll be a coke zero,
which I'm telling you getting crazy. It saves me,
I don't get in and out, but I'll have this coke there that'll be okay.
Can in and out fucking with, you know, and then now it's amazing. It's,
that's God's gift to us that this is,
this is for everyone in Texas. I'm so sorry, but in and out is $1 million now.
No, they're in Dallas. They're Austin then new Braunfels. Yeah.
Those Water Burger people are, they're drinking the Koolaid.
It's wrong fucking mind. If you're comparing water burger,
you've got to compare it to like McDonald's, to Burger King.
And that's a different show like this. This is the different tickets.
Only people that fuck with in and out. It's five guys. Okay, five guys.
But if you go to Austin, and where we're on it is, if you go out there,
there's this place called p toes. There's only three or four of them,
and they're only in that area. I'm telling you, they crush.
Everybody appreciated. Terry P, Terry's daughter,
Terry Terry crews like t e R, y, apostrophe s,
and I'm telling you this is not a sponsored ad.
They are the fucking shit and their fries in and knots. Pfizer. Okay.
They're not the best. I think guys had better fries. Way Better way.
Legend fries. And they have better burger choices too. Weird Jalapenos.
Exactly. Of Shakes. They don't have shakes. Oh,
they do have shakes and then that's got pretty good chicks too. Yeah.
The five guy didn't have shakes for awhile. Now they have shakes at some places,
but they win with the Jalapenos. Oh yeah, I'll pianos in Bacon. More options.
Yeah. They can't fuck with that. Better buns too. Yeah. Way Better buns.
But when you go to Austin, you got to try be Derrick's hungry now.
We left the, we left evil live too last night in the limo and I was like,
we've been here for nine hours. We're stopping to in and out to the, I was like,
you've had it in and out. I was like, no, I've had it.
We're just stopping that damn p Terry's bang for your Burger.
That does God damn good. That looks so good.
And they're only in that area to really, they need to branch the fuck out.
That looks fantastic. Yeah. Woo Man. Next time we're there. For sure. Yeah.
Mean so I'm, what about supplements? Like vitamins, minerals,
actually a protein is,
is something I definitely stick to and I do pre-workouts, uh,
depending on like what mood I'm in, what kind of protein powder use.
I am spoiled. I do the RTDs like the way to do drinks. Like guys,
I'll get those cases at Costco. Man, Costco's always got great deals, but um,
I like to basically use whatever's easy on my stomach, you know, like, like way.
Do you like pea protein, hemp? What do you like? I've had,
I've had P P was okay. It tasted kind of funny. Um, real weird. Hemp Hens. Nice.
And Saul is nice and if you can for me,
like it's just nice to go back to that. Like just the honest stuff.
No on it. Like, Shit, I wish I had some here.
I'll give you some no on him. Fuck.
Maybe we'll see. It's always nice, man. Whatever you need.
It's always nice to go back to the hemp,
like for anything for like if you're doing clothes or anything like that.
It's just so easy to digest to hemp protein. Just like go, goes, no problem.
Nice. Yeah, it's my favorite. Yeah. And then so I'll do,
I'll do press and stuff like that. I actually work with a,
a company called Nana suitable solutions that does do vitamins.
And it's basically, I'm gonna fuck this all up concussions. Don't,
don't fucking don't email me telling me I fucked this up.
I'm telling you right now. I fucked this up. God Damn Email Joe. Okay.
Email Joe. That's why. So Nana Nana suitable solutions.
They take uh,
like basically your normal vitamins and they break them down into a smaller bit.
Like normally the smallest way you can. You can, um,
it's called bio, like the way your body injustice, it's called bioavailability.
There you go. Thank you. That was going to bug me. So the,
so for your body to actually accept that like the lowest we've gotten this to I
think micro grams or something like that and the sky out of San Antonio,
he broke it down into nanograms and he will, he's been working with me.
I think I'm the only athlete he works with. He's a small company and um,
we've been talking, we were working together and I could just tell right away.
I used to do B 12 shots.
You ever had to be 12 shots and you know how right afterwards you kind of taste
that weird taste in your mouth and you get that energy with him.
He has the sublingual vitamins.
So like between the B12 and the glutosiome dude,
I'm telling you like the B12, it was just like getting the B12 shot.
What's the name of his company?
Nana ceuticals solutions Nano ceuticals solution go. Got It.
Proprietary manufacturing process allows for the molecular dispersion without
excessive heat or breaking of the chemical bonds.
This allows the vitamins and supplements to remain unchanged and undamaged when
they are absorbed in your body. Fucking them in exactly what I said. Right,
exactly. Methyl B12, Melatonin,
gludethyon gluten islands, a shish. Nobody knows about her Americans or Kumon.
I just found out that tumeric has an RNA. I learned it this year.
I learned that from you was like,
I thought it was tumeric. We're so stupid.
We are reptiles for sure. You and I for sure. So I do that.
They've got smart people out there making vitamins that nanograms. Exactly.
So I just try and eat clean and that kind of stuff. You know and it's,
you can,
we can always tell when our bodies like act a little weird and funny and you can
just backtrack a little bit and you're like, oh,
like I've been doing this a little different.
I've had beer fucking six nights in a row. Like just chill out.
That kind of shit. Yeah. So most of the time it's self regulation.
Now you said that they drug test, you guys, what are they testing for a,
they test for everything. When we get drug tested at world's strongest man,
that's for everything. It's steroids for steroids. It's full.
Everybody has to be on steroids. No I don't. I mean,
I don't know what to tell you when there's one test a year. Right?
So you have one test that test,
you have to pass that test and they can test you randomly to randomly thing on
the, from my experience,
the random thing only happens if you're acting like you're on amphetamines.
If you're acting like you're on amphetamines, they're going to test you.
And there's been guys who pop for amphetamines after they randomly tested them
to try to put us off. Exactly.
If you're screaming at somebody about cocking sock and all that,
you're going to get drug tested. Oh,
so that's what I would imagine that they would worry about that when it comes to
lifting. Right. Definitely. You don't want somebody to gut die on their right.
You know you can have that and more like pulling that truck. I'm telling you,
they stopped using the heart meters because people were losing their fucking
mind. Seeing that in our hearts were so high. It was like two 40 a minute,
like maybe two 30 yeah, it's insane. You could get that high.
That's what everybody else said. So they pulled the fucking meters.
Oh my God, dude, that's like a Jack Rabbit. Crazy. Huh. Wow.
Two 40 a minute. Fucking A.
Does anybody pissed hot for steroids? Uh,
I believe one person got busted. I would imagine,
I don't want to say his name cause I don't know if it was for steroids or for,
uh, a Meth, meth amphetamine.
That makes sense. But I mean, I got to feel like for steroids, I kinda,
I mean I don't wanna like push it, but it seems like you'd have to be,
I mean it's, it's a sport where it's a, it's built for bigger men,
but there's a lot of guys who have gone through and been very adamant that
they're not.
And you know, we get tested. We will literally,
like every year I have to explain to the guy like, yes,
there's going to be marijuana in my system.
And that's in the rules that says it's okay.
Like I have that conversation every year and it used to be illegal.
You should be illegal. And we got to, we got to switched,
I believe 14 [inaudible] switch. I brought it up a lot.
I don't know if that really changed anything, but I was like,
look at these fucking gorillas.
You want everyone here on Vicodin and like I w I literally like all I'm saying
is we should be able to smoke weed.
I'm not saying you guys should be able to do math or any of that other shit.
None of that.
Like I think we're finally recognizing finally as a culture that weed is not
what everybody thought it was. They were in the 50s and the 30s and thank God,
thank God. Cause I mean people were doing so much worse shit.
Well that's why that little Jeff sessions cut was driving me fucking crazy when
he was the attorney general and he was saying we've gotta you know,
marijuana is good. People don't smoke marijuana like you.
You're not hanging around with good people first of all because good people
don't want to hang out with you. Exactly.
You don't know what you're talking and wasn't,
it wasn't a Hilary that was saying he was,
she was going to do her best to keep it illegal. Yeah.
She had some nonsense that she was saying too. That was, I don't know.
She be fucking, who knows? That's crazy. If I was you, I,
and just being honest on the show would scare the living fuck out of me because
so many people listen. I just be worried that sooner or later,
like you know somebody before you just show up, Hillary just shows up.
This show I'm going to carry on one of them.
That kings that carry with the Poles on the shoulders, she just comes in,
moves the veil and peaks. Yes.
That is the one that you see that a video I put on my Instagram with that dude
who Trump. Yeah.
I was out with a Hillary head inside the body that was so bad ass.
Who is that guy?
Let's give that guy some props cause that fucking animation's amazing. Put It,
put it up on, on the big screen.
It's like one of those things where like how does this guy even think of this
and where is he buying his wheat?
This is not something that a regular person thinks of people. Crap, B,
p. L, e. Underscore, c. R. A. P. And. A.
He's got this video of this Trump robot with glowing eyes and one artificial leg
moving and the entire body of the Trump robot is Hillary's giant head floating
around in a vat of liquid, like a war torn United States.
I'm guessing soldiers marching with them. Yeah.
At some apocalyptic post-apocalyptic scenario.
But there's all these lights and it's fucking amazing. It's so dope.
And Trump's body is weird and his feet are like baby feet in his hand.
Yeah, I always get that. They do their best to just fuck with that.
Cause it bothers him. He should've never acted like it bothered him.
Did he act like it bothered him? I think he said something about my hand,
these big hands after they'd said it. I don't know. That's hilarious.
That's the thing is, is every, every dude knows.
Like if a guy flinches when you say some shit or say some more of that shit,
that's what you do. Exactly. You're not supposed to flinch.
But they're the ones who say you don't body shame.
I mean while their body shaming this poor guy a little,
he doesn't even have little hands, but normal hands rules don't exist anymore.
Oh, that's hilarious. It's like a gorilla. Yeah. If I was Trump,
I would hire a trainer and just get on the best juice too.
If I had apps like that, I'd never wear a shirt.
I'd go to funerals without a shirt on. Yeah. Sorry Bro, you dead.
But I'm [inaudible] put a sock on your cock. I don't,
yeah, I don't, I don't think Trump has little hands. They're regular hands,
but it is a constant theme to hers.
But that thing that Beepo crap guy does that you say his name beatable
underscore crap. He's amazing. Got some great shit on his page too.
That's really cool. God Damn. Look at that giant Kim Giang robot.
Cause I wasn't Trump just in Korea right now. We partying with that dude.
They'd probably killed somebody together.
I wonder if it was like the interview way.
Let them drive the tank and they were listening to my Miley Cyrus was in Miley
Cyrus. What was it? Um, I don't remember.
It wasn't my only listen to in the movie, the interview,
they were driving around.
I don't remember. Yeah, that was the Seth Rogen movie. Hilarious movement,
by the way. I never saw that movie. Oh, you've got to see that shit.
It's fucking clips. You got to see that one. That's good.
That movie like vanished. Like I forgot about it until you just brought it up.
I was like, Oh yeah, Netflix. I'm sure it is. Yeah. All of those. All of those,
like from Superbad got me like I wasn't allowed to for back's hilarious scene
when they were good at sex. When you go to college,
you want to be sucking Dick at fucking pussy. So good.
Who wrote that shit? Tell me who wrote. That's all I can say. Thank you.
I don't know man, but the scene, what? He's just drawn. Dick's
ridiculous. Crazy. I love movies like that.
Just preposterous shit. Just like relaxed humor. Yeah.
He didn't care if it bothered somebody and he wasn't trying to be a dick,
but he was funny. Well, what's interesting is that was quite a few years ago.
I wonder if they would even do that movie that way today. That's it.
You know it was like 2013 or something movie coming out about three younger kids
than the super bad movie and it's rated r and it seems like it's right along
that same vein of like humorous comedy and thank God we need more of that.
It's like the backlash is stronger now than ever before.
But also the appreciation of it is stronger now than ever before too because
people are so tired of people being so politically correct and so upset about
everything. You know like no one's telling you to be an asshole,
but people are jumping on things that aren't even bad. Right.
It's like I was, I'm actually like a little nervous
about telling athletes that they should smoke weed now.
Like [inaudible] that's nerve wracking cause like you're hold dependent,
you're depending on, on your boss in the places you work in, the things you do.
Right. So just saying something like that,
if two people find that offensive and they raised enough house,
sure that's a big fucking deal. But w what we're just saying is like,
it's better than Viking and it's better than hills. It's,
it's a very much healthier alternative alternative. Um, alternative.
Well, you know what it is, man, it's a tool. It's like you can abuse tools,
but you could also use them correctly. I mean,
you don't want to fucking hammer nails with a saw, right? But,
but if you use marijuana correctly and you have discipline and you know what
you're doing, if the problem is that it's been illegal for so long,
people don't understand what the best way to use it for is.
And what are the side effects? What is the w you know, what's the paranoia?
What's this heightened sense of awareness that kind of freaks people out?
Like how do ya, how do you mitigate that? How do you,
how do you get over what's the right dosage?
All that stuff is dependent upon information.
And when people aligned to you about it being terrible and you know,
making you fucking blind and losing your marbles and you're going to kill
people. Just stuff.
People are so confused about it that it also makes you more paranoid because as
you're smoking you think, and I'm like, God, I shouldn't be doing this.
What am I doing? I'm ruining my life. I can't believe I'm doing that.
And then you get even more paranoid and then you're like,
I'm never doing this again. Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. Now what about sponsors?
Is it ever an issue with sponsors?
The weed thing would be, would be, oh my,
right now the only people I work with other than myself is that Nana suitable
solutions. So he's actually working on doing a CBD thing and stuff.
I don't know if I'll be a part of that cause I'm trying to, there's,
it's so available now. I just,
I'd rather just find whoever does it the very best to not not marketing because
it's so saturated. I just take it from myself. Actually a lot of people. I,
I worked in group homes when I was in college for kids with autism on um,
for, for a long time. And there was actually this little girl who, uh,
she had this, this uh, it's not a disease. She had this, uh,
I'll just call it a thing.
She had this thing where she always felt that she was falling. So,
so like she looked completely normal.
She was autistic and nonverbal didn't speak,
but imagine all day feeling like you're falling.
So she learned as a child really little if she would hit herself,
that people would hold her. So if you weren't holding her,
she would literally ask, watched her break her own nose and like she was,
she was 11 years old, this, this sweet little girl,
like just super nice and Smiley, but like if you didn't hold her,
she just wacked ran her own face and we found out that through,
I don't remember exactly how it came about, but they, they gave her THC pills,
they gave her THC pills and then stopped.
She would walk around the house normally like she was still nonverbal.
It's not like a fixed her autism or any of that stuff,
but with the whole symptoms of feeling like she was falling,
which I'm sure I don't even think had anything to do with autism. Again,
I'm not a doctor, but um, but again,
yeah you got to worry about that shit. So uh,
they gave her THC pills and she was like just walking around the house smiling.
She would help us cook.
She would move around like she would help the other kids cause it was four kids
in the house. She would help the other kids tie their shoes, stuff like that.
Oh that's true. Then her parents came back,
must've been four months later and their friends had guilted them about giving
her dog their daughter weed and they stopped giving it to her and she went right
back to it. Went straight back to it. So stupid. It's just ignorance.
People just don't understand what it is. That's all it is. Yeah.
Oh that's so sad. I felt so bad.
It was one of the things that like just rip me apart from working in that field
is just, there's so much,
like there's these little rules that you don't understand.
We had a kid that would sit right and he would just,
he would feel stressed out and he would sit and the rule was when he did that,
we weren't allowed to help him up or move him or anything like that because that
was rewarding bad behavior. That's how they classified that.
So he would just sit in the middle of the road and we weren't allowed to get him
out of the middle of the road. He would, he would.
And then he learned that if he didn't want to do something,
if he basically would stay in his room all day,
he would stay in his room all day because he didn't like the only worker he
liked was me. And I think it was just cause that was big and jolly and all that.
But if you didn't like the person who was working with,
he just sit in his room on the floor and then they couldn't touch him.
They couldn't do anything and he'd just sit there.
He'd go days without eating or going anywhere out of the room or anything like
that.
And it was all because we'd put these rules in and put these chains on ourselves
based off of other people's opinions or worrying what it would look like if we
did this. You know, if this girl is taking this pill, what does that look like?
Or if we're picking this boy up off the ground, what does that look like?
And it was, it was, it was,
it was like trying to help these children with your hands tied behind your back.
And I don't know if it's like that anymore. It was, this was a long time ago,
but it was just, it was heartbreaking.
I remember everyone was terrified to work with this little boy.
He was 10 or 11 he was just a sweet little dude. He just didn't,
he got nervous, you know? And so I remember coming in and one day I was like,
you know what, I'm taking him to go to a football game.
So I took him to a college division one football game. Never had an issue.
Never had any problems, never sat down, nothing.
Sat second row in the end zone and like would get all excited every time anybody
came or like the cannon went off for a touchdown.
It was like the greatest moment of my whole like college career was hanging out
with this 11 year old at a college football game that people were too terrified
to even get out of this room. That's terrible.
But that's so cool that he got them there though. Yeah.
I'd like to think that a lot of people work more
in that direction after I left. You know, I'm hoping that he was,
you could see in his eyes he was a sweet little boy. You know, you,
you can see there's, I've never met a kid that was evil ever.
You just need to know how to, how to work with them, how to talk with them.
Well, that's cool that you have that kind of patience. Yeah.
Do you have kids of your own? I do. I have a three year old boy. Oh, nice. Yeah.
My little atlas by first one, three year old. Wow. That's a,
that's a fun age man.
They start talking to Ya and they're running around telling all the stories and
everything and now he doesn't even like,
like we have to read books before we go to bed cause when we go to bed he wants
to tell me stories. So he'll lay there and he'll be like,
well this one time and he'll talk for like 10 minutes about some shit. You know?
It's, it's so sweet and so cute. Yeah, it's a wild thing.
Having a little person that made people that don't experience it,
it's very, very hard to describe. Yeah. It's like the sweetest,
most lovey, most intense sweetness you've ever felt in your life.
Yet the scariest fucking, most horrifying thing at the exact same time. Right.
You just feel so vulnerable. Yeah. Vulnerable is a great word for it.
I also have so much more compassion for other people now because I think of
other people now as babies that grew up where I used to think,
oh look at this asshole. And I was think,
oh that asshole used to be a little baby. Like someone's a little boy.
Someone's carrying him and holding him and he just got bad information and now
he's all fucked up. Yeah. Yeah. I saw some homeless guy today.
I was at a stop light. He was wearing a bathrobe,
got a bathrobe and socks on as it just dirty,
fucked up and I was looking at him like this. That was someone's baby boy. Yeah.
Now here he is, a guy in his thirties or forties whatever.
He was just wandering around,
all fucked up and dirty with mental health problems wearing in a bathrobe and
I'm like, they used to be someone's boy. Yup. That's,
it's good for you to feel that way, but it's rough to live like that. Well,
it's, it's,
it's so hard when you look at all the problems in the world and all the people
that are suffering from poverty and disease and strife and natural disasters and
all these things, there's just so many people to care about and think about.
It's almost like you can become paralyzed with compassion. Just stuff.
I'm really just looking at all the problems with the world. Yeah.
And then the other side of it,
the one that gets me a lot is like when you see parents or you hear about
parents, I haven't seen it a lot,
but you hear about parents who just don't give a fuck who it's like this.
This is a burden on me and they avoid it and digit I.
When you look at your daughter's eyes,
have you ever once in your life imagine being able to walk away from that? No.
Fuck that. That would kill me.
I heard a story about a lady who abandoned her kids the other day.
I just couldn't imagine that she abandoned her kids and wanting to start fresh
left the husband with the kids just left. Wow.
And I was just sitting there going, what in the fuck?
And then the fires came and their fucking house burnt down. Wow.
And so then, so here they are, the dad and the kids, daughters
and the mom fucking jet and the guys. They're no house.
Fuck. I'm like God, Jesus Christ man. Yeah man, it's,
it's rough cause you gotta wonder like what is wrong with that person?
Like what kind of schizophrenia they dealing with kind mental health issues.
Like what is, how could you do that?
Like how do you not like you think about what you experienced with your son and
I think about what I experienced with my daughters and like how could you,
how could you not want to be there for them?
How could you not want to take care of them?
How could you not want to love them? It's there's some kind of disconnect man.
Yeah. What happened? Well,
I mean you think about that poor girl who kept punching herself in the face
because she thought she was falling. Like there's obviously an issue there.
Like what other issues are there psychologically with empathy issues,
detachments, you know sociopathy like what,
what's wrong with them? That they're allowed,
that they can allow that in their life. So you know, there's too,
almost too many people, man, it's almost too much to pay attention to.
Yeah. Well, I mean legitimately it's hard to say whether it is too much. Yeah.
It's hard to say that and accepted, but it is. I mean,
that's how a lot of people end up going crazy. Paralyzed from fear.
Worry. Yeah. That's where we comes in. Yes.
You just worry about other shit. Think about aliens.
Aliums if you had to guess,
I'll turn it around on you. What do you think about aliens?
Do you think Bob was ours? Telling the truth.
I don't even look them in the eye because you weren't in the room with them.
Yeah, but I told you I want, I'm the one of the,
the creepers that watched the youtube video.
I'm that guy right there that I sit at home. I don't really watch much TV.
Like I'll sit at home and like stretch and watch, uh, watch these videos.
So it's,
I think it's a whole new thing to it like adds an element that I really like,
like being able to see miss pat did. Oh yeah. Fucking hilarious.
Like my entire time I was like glued everybody.
I mean,
I've never funny when she talks about broke dudes are great at slings day,
you know, I love his art. Ari's subtleness like, Oh man,
he's fucking hilarious.
I would imagine that for like a guy who's doing such ruthless fucking explosive
shit like you're doing all the time,
like comedy must be kind of important for sure. It's a huge release. Put some,
you know,
like I like it and a lot of my friends were that like I was friends with a lot
of guys at the comedy store, so I was around it. Like I,
I even thought about doing it for awhile. I just,
I know I'd have to dedicate so much to even be decent that I just couldn't do
that. But like it's one of those things I like to take.
Tried it for a little bit. Yeah. Yeah. I was with him.
I was hanging out with them a lot when he was working on material and stuff.
I remember he came over and he gave me a, this bad-ass Poncho.
One time he just randomly came over to give me a Poncho and then was like date
and then we wanted to hang out and when we were sitting out on my deck and we
had this boy, he was working, we were just chilling. He was, he's like,
it's so cool. One of the, what's that quote?
It's better to be a warrior and a garden and a gardener in a war. Yes.
That's state by state. Yeah, and that's similar to you.
It's a lot of guys like that. You see a lot of these guys who are just,
they're built, ready to go. You know? Like if if some shit went down, like I,
I would happily stand next to you. You know, like I'd be, I'd be,
I'd feel like secure,
but you don't have to worry about like if you're coming here,
you're not going to have no fake lats syndrome and flex up on some asshole.
That's one of the things you do see with fighters too,
is that most of them in general, they're really nice people. Yeah.
As soon as they don't, they're not always puffing their chest out for no reason.
Act like an asshole for no reason. They're nice folks. Yeah.
They get all that shit out. They get it out in the gym.
If you're a bad motherfucker, you don't have to act like a bad motherfucker.
You just be, you exactly know.
That's why I wear pink Chuck's and strong and pretty shirts and shit. You know,
like I don't have to act like I'm bad that it's doing well.
No one's disputing it. Exactly. Exactly. There's a long line. They sometimes do.
Oh, of course. Who are they? Are they even real? That's the people I'm saying.
I'm not a doctor for oh, for them, but for the aliens.
Um, what do you think he had a bad, if I, if he had 100 bucks,
your last hundred bucks. It's hard. I,
if I had 100 bucks and we were going to find that,
I'd say I'm leaning more toward just them now. I'm looking more towards yes to,
I wasn't leaning before that interview. I wasn't though.
I wasn't before the documentary that Jeremy Corbell documentary,
Bob Lasar area 51 and flying saucers before that.
I was like mostly bullshit because that one is that one available.
Like Netflix is great. Yeah, I'll check those.
A lot of old bibles are shit too from the George Knapp interviews where he goes
over the,
the details of the craft and he describes it and explains it and the fucker knew
about element one 15 in the 1990s that's, that's,
that's one of the big ones that gets me. That's one of the big ones.
That's like, that's a big red flag that this dude's real. This isn't a lot.
Who knows? But there's a lot that makes me go,
I know you talk about this all the time,
but I so fucking wish Sasquatch was real too. Man.
Every time I'm in Oregon or Washington, I'm walking around,
I buy all the little like roadside trinkets and shit. I love that shit.
I wish it was fucking real man. It would be nice.
But I think we was on a deadline. It's, I mean that's,
that's one of the ones I'm like 90% sure. You got to give,
you always gotta give room. You always got to give room for the possibility.
The thing is some people really believe and then go looking for it.
They invest so much time and if they start going crazy like survivor man,
Les Stroud. Yes. It's gone. Gone, gone. Gone. He's out there in the woods. Yeah.
He's got a pup tent for bigfoot, not fucking zippers. It's weird man.
He's 100% believer now and he does that for survivor man. Big Foot show.
He's like what? I heard a branch snap, not the commercial.
That's definitely a squatch. Yeah. Those shows are weird man,
because those shows
have been on TV like surviving bigfoot or finding bigfoot rather.
So finding bigfoot was on TV for what? Eight fucking years.
They never found shit. No like how the fuck do you keep renewing that shit?
I'm going to breathe underwater. The show. It's called breathing underwater.
Can you breathe under water? Not yet. Tune in next week. Next season though,
we're going to try to breathe underwater. The shit out of y'all.
Just give us an off season. We'll get this talking to these scientists.
They're saying no one can breathe under water. Not yet. They don't know shit.
Trust South Louisiana. We got a guy he breathes on the water. If,
if there was a big foot, no one be happier than me. Dude,
I'd be right there though. I was so fucking stoked, man.
I just seen it in a cage. Just fucking trying to get out.
Looking around and no, not cage though. I want to see it like in a,
in a destiny like the mushrooms trip where he's like walking and singing with
him. Oh, Jack blocks. Pick a X. Pick a destiny. Pick of destiny.
I would want to be there. I want to want to see it with my own eyes. For sure.
Video. I'd be like, man,
I saw 80 foot tall Donald Trump with a Hillary Clinton head.
Power walk you through a post apocalyptic Philadelphia. You can't,
you can't prove to me that video's real. I mean, you see it. I would,
I would shit my pants. I don't know what I would say though,
if I was in the woods and I was camping and I saw a fucking nine foot tall
gorilla. I Dunno what I would say. You wouldn't,
I mean if you came back you probably have to. Yeah, cause you'd be so,
you feel so stupid. Oh, plus I mean there's a lot.
I mean say there is one out there.
There's a lot of bullshit artists out there telling you they saw some shit.
You know a lot of people trying to get some camera time.
They can't be one though. If it's going to be a real thing, a living thing,
that has to be a living population of them. Yeah,
because primates don't live that long.
I don't think there's a primary that lives any older than humans. We're just,
we're just way into the weeds. But no, that doesn't exist.
This most likely success. Yeah.
As they get better and better at like using drones and scanning the forest and
stuff, it's getting less and less likely. Yeah.
I used to do that as a kid though.
Like walk out in the woods and like look and hope it was around, you know, hope.
Yeah. When I was living in Oregon, I was like,
hell's canyon is probably one of the least explored parts of Oregon.
If he was anyway, he'd be up there, you know?
Well there's some dense ass thick forest in the Pacific northwest,
which is one of the reasons why I think it's so attractive because you think
like, man, hey thing could be in here. No one knows. Right?
Like you go outside of Philadelphia or excuse me, Seattle.
When you go into a like, you know, what is it? What's the mountain out there?
What's the sat Helen say now this is the one that blue,
but there's another one that, anyway, those big ass mountains filled with soup.
There's, the trees are so dense, it's like a box of Q tips,
just one after the other bang, Bang, Bang, Bang, Bang,
and the forest floor is all pine needles so that nothing would leave a footprint
and then you look, you're like, what if you saw something 30 yards away?
It could disappear instantly left, right.
You wouldn't know where the fuck it is. You'd never find it. And it could,
it could be out there. So I think that also leads to this,
this delusional idea that it might be alive. Right.
But I think it definitely was a real thing back in the day. Yeah.
They have that gigantic [inaudible] yeah. That they proven was a,
a real, uh, bipedal hominid that existed at,
as recently as 100,000 years ago. And it will America, no, it was in Asia.
They found an apothecary shop.
There was a anthropologist who was in an apothecary,
found a teeth and he was like, what the fuck is this? And they said, uh,
we found these. And he's like, where'd you find these?
Cause you recognize it as primate teeth. And then they,
they start digging and they found job bones that were indicative of a bipedal
hominid because of the, the shape of the job on,
they could tell the difference between like the way a gorillas burnt bones are
shaped and the way ours are.
And they think it was in the orangutan family that it was enormous.
Some it enormous fucking eight to 10 foot tall by peatal ape. Yeah.
So stories that build and build them to set them. That's probably where the,
the lore and the legend comes from.
You never seen like a picture of what it looks like.
I remember you talking about it on here. I don't remember. Um,
if I saw a picture, you could find it on Google.
There's pictures of it standing next to like a standard, you know,
like six foot tall man.
Like what a regular size man would be like standing next to this giant ass
fucking gorilla really did live.
It really did live and it lived alongside people while people were real people.
They know at least a hundred thousand years ago it was alive. That's,
that's what it looked like. Oh Shit. Yeah. That's a depiction of them.
There's a, there's a few different versions of that.
We'll get that other shit with the harm up in the Air Jamie and the lower right
hand corner. No, no, no, no. Go, go up, up,
go see those pictures. I see that when you have those little pictures and the,
the little windows below it. She the one with his arm up in the air. Yeah.
Click that one. That's the one. That's what it looked like.
I shit with fuck you up to yeah, probably super fast.
It's Kinda like a rank tan looking.
That's what they think their thinking was kind of a member of the orangutan
family. But it was a real thing.
But it's just funny how like we want those things to be real.
We want mysteries to be real.
It's part of the reasons why you have to really worry or wonder whether or not
someone's telling the truth because of the desire for something to be real.
So strong. Right? Like UFO, the same thing.
People want to believe God so hard to be objective.
What about with all that stuff hotep was saying on here?
Cause like a lot of it he sounds like way more intelligent than I was expecting
when I first turned it on. I didn't really know much about him,
but I mean about Africans traveling the world in boats.
Well about them being in America first or about them,
like giving that technology to Rome. He said a lot of stuff that like,
I mean obviously I'm a meat head
and I'm not like the smartest man on the planet,
but he's made a lot of sense from what he was saying. Well,
for sure when people think about Africa, they forget about Egypt.
And Egypt is one of the most fascinating and absolutely spectacularly advanced
civilizations of all time. We have no idea how they built those structures.
There's all this speculation about the,
especially like the Great Pyramid of just this,
a stunning technological and physical accomplishment that to this day baffles
people. That's Africa. So those people at boats,
and we don't even know how long, I mean Graham Hancock believes and so does uh,
Robert Schoch and um, John Anthony West, when he was alive,
believed that those people were building those things tens of thousands of years
ago. That,
that that is like a spectacularly creative and innovative society that was most
likely wiped out by some sort of global capitalism around 12,000 years ago.
And then everything after that was a rebuilding of past knowledge. Right.
So it would make sense if they had traveled to south, uh,
south parts of America and then just basically everything got wiped out.
And so they're,
they're working from a fresh start in America and then over on this side,
they don't have the information about that because they all got wiped out. Well,
it certainly makes sense that you look at the Omex, those deals,
giant stone heads, it looked like African faces, right? I mean,
they look exactly like Africans and these [inaudible] heads that came from
thousands and thousands of years ago in a civilization.
The omex that they know very little about. Yeah.
So I felt like,
I felt like I was crazy for thinking he wasn't crazy for some of the shit he was
saying. It's like the history of humans is something that becomes more,
it unveils itself over time.
And the more they're starting to find new things,
like there was something of the law,
there was some ancient castle that they just discovered that used to be
underwater. That's like 3000, 500 years old.
And I'm talking about the receding floodwater. Yeah, yeah. They found like,
what the fuck is this? They don't like, they don't even know what it is.
So 3,500 years ago,
long before Europeans ever came to America,
these people built this fucking castle that is now underwater.
You're like the sea levels rise and fall. That's it. Yeah.
Where is the things in Iraq? Oh yeah, it is in Iraq. Yeah,
so they found these ancient, now Iraq is also where Sumir was.
That's the,
the earliest known civilization in terms of the earliest known writing,
the earliest known agriculture in mathematics. That's Sumar,
that's epic of Gilgamesh. All that shit came from that part of the world.
So there's all sorts of stuff that was probably lost in that, you know,
thousands and thousands of years of history. It's amazing.
It's so fascinating to be there. Just like,
I like this place that I was in in Italy,
there's a church in Ravello that's a thousand years old and below the church is
a glass floor. The church. There's pictures of it on my, and it's
a glass floor of the church and below the glass for is that is another church
that's so old. They don't even know when it was built. Oh. So it's more that.
That's it. That's from my, my Instagram. So fucking cool. So that,
that they have it like blocked off and they put a glass floor over it so you
could look down and see it because they don't want people to tread on it and
fuck with it. But the church itself,
just that the church that you could walk around in is a thousand years old.
You know what? And we're working off information.
That's basically just been since we started writing things down.
We've got this little short time period where we started writing things down.
I mean acting almost as though that was the beginning of time.
And you have to take people's word for it. Exactly. Exactly. No pictures,
no video. Same thing with the aliens and the Sasquatch.
There's some things that you want to believe. So throw that in there.
And history was written by the winners. Exactly. So bunch of lion assholes.
It killed everybody.
Like the chair is my friend.
My son loves that song between that one, and we will rock you. We've got,
we were in a limo yesterday and he was like, put on, we will rock you.
So I'm cranking. We will rock you. My three year olds in the back deal. Boom,
boom. She's so excited. That's awesome.
When you think about fucking classic songs, Man Queen had a gay,
a classic songs that just worldwide to this day that are used it.
Basketball Games and football games all over the world. Yeah. Huge.
Such a icon. Yeah. John Jones came out to, we are the champions. Yeah.
This was this last one. Yeah. Nice. I didn't get to see the fights that,
how did I know John went to a, it was a split decision, right?
How did the fight fight? Man, fucking Tiago Santos is danger us.
He hit John with some big shots,
fucked his legs up with kicks to the point where John had to be carried out when
he, when he walked out of the octagon, they were carrying him. He couldn't walk.
His legs were fucked up.
That guy kicked the shit out of his legs and Tiago blew his knee out somewhere
in the first, we believe he threw a kick and blew his ACL out,
but never even winced. He,
you around that knee and just kept throwing kicks with it and everything. Yeah,
I'm crazy. It was an awesome fight. Your think, uh, he fought was, again,
this is, I'm not projecting anything. I didn't get to see the fight.
Did he fight well enough to suffer it extensive damage to left knee out for the
rest of 2008 well, there goes the question. I was just saying.
You think you earned another shot? Well, he, he definitely did. He proved,
yeah, he had a split decision. What, what's up complete?
Ligament's torn in his left knee. Oh yeah. There you go. Yeah, I kind of,
we kind of saw it looking at it. Yeah.
Shows left knee meniscus and all his ligaments are completely torn. Wow.
The meniscus and all the ligaments, that's Jesus Christ.
And he still stood in there for four fucking rounds.
He needed surgery on his right knee earlier this year.
Also suffered damage during the fight as he compensated for his left knee.
Oh Man.
So he doesn't even know if he might need tests on his right knee as well.
But you know what the good news is that UFC doctors are the top of the food
chain.
They'll fill that motherfucker up with stem cells and do everything they can of
rebuild some of that inner tissue. He deserves it.
If you're going to stand in them and put it all in the line like that, you know,
give the man his fucking stem cells. If they fight again,
Jon Jones fucking power doubles him. Takes him to the ground. So yeah,
I mean I think, I don't, I'm a, I was shocked that he didn't do it. I saw,
I read, um,
I don't know if it was on his page or on the ones like MMA junkie or something,
but um, he said that he,
it was pride he didn't want to do that cause that's crazy. That's John Though.
But the pride almost cost him the title. Yeah. Like,
what if Tiago clipped him and dropped him in the third round and then he won
that round on all the judges scorecards and then he wanted decision. Yeah,
he almost lost the title. We can look crazy. I mean I don't,
I don't agree necessarily with the guy who give it to gave it to Tiago.
I'd have to watch it and see how they thought it and yeah, cause when you're,
when you're calling a fight, I'm trying to be entertaining.
I'm looking for patterns, but I'm not really scoring it to score it.
I think you have to do it in silence. Yeah.
So I'd have to see whether or not I agreed with them,
but it was definitely close.
It was definitely interesting and a lot more interesting.
A lot of people thought,
a lot of people thought John was going to blow them out of the water.
And that's what I was expecting. I've messed around just like, you know,
like Bro, like, like uh,
pushing him around and stuff like that and he's way stronger than I would
expect. Oh, he's strong. It's fucked. Last Shit. He took Daniel Cormier down,
you know, I mean he's a mother fucker dude.
And I think when he goes up to heavyweight he's going to be even stronger.
And I think that's probably what's going to happen next with Sean before they
fucking should winter steepen the dental fighting that's out here in August.
August. That is um, yeah, that's an August. And that's at Anaheim. Yeah. Um,
man, DC and Steve Bay too. That should be very interesting too.
I don't even know who to root for it cause I fucking love stupid. I love him.
But like I, I've got,
I feel like I have to love Daniel cause everyone else for no fucking reason
doesn't like they do now.
You think they're more and more he's getting Manuel's turned good turn cause he
fucking deserves it. You know, I mean he's,
he's a bad motherfucker initially knocked out Steve pay one punch that,
that turned the tide good. Good for him when he beat Anthony Johnson,
that turned the tie. People get it now for awhile though.
They were like looking at him like he's a legitimate, absurd. Well,
welcome to the world of MMA pedes versus DSS on that car to l yellow Romero
versus Polo Kosta. Woo. All right,
brother. What's wrapped this up? It's already three o'clock.
We've been doing this for three hours. Holy Shit. Crazy time flies.
So tell people again, uh, when this show is on the history channel,
we're on a Wednesday nights. It's strongest man in history with the me,
myself, and, um, Eddie Hall. Brian, Sean, Nick,
best you can check me out on Instagram. Just Robert Oberst over the a s t site.
Beautiful. Thank you brother. That was awesome, man. A lot of fun.
Thank you very much. Bye everybody.
[inaudible]
okay.
[inaudible].